Hey there, Shankar here. We wanted to give our listeners a heads-up that we're hiring here at Hidden Brain. We're currently looking for a marketing and promotions assistant to help us connect our editorial work with fans across multiple platforms. You can find more information at hiddenbrain.org slash jobs. We also anticipate we'll be bringing more staff on board to help us with writing, producing, and editing video scripts for YouTube and social media platforms. We don't have job descriptions for those roles posted yet,
大家好，我是Shankar。我们想提醒听众朋友们，Hidden Brain目前正在招聘。我们正在寻找一位市场营销与推广助理，帮助我们将编辑工作与各平台的粉丝联系起来。您可以在hiddenbrain.org/jobs找到更多信息。我们预计未来还会招聘更多员工，协助我们为YouTube和社交媒体平台撰写、制作和编辑视频脚本。目前这些职位的职位描述尚未发布，
but if you have experience in video production for these platforms, we'd love to hear from you. You can send your resume and a cover letter to jobs at hiddenbrain.org. Thanks for your interest in working with us. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. There are moments in any journey when things can feel interminable. You show up to work every day. Do the same job.
但如果您有这些平台的视频制作经验，我们非常希望能收到您的来信。您可以将简历和求职信发送至jobs@hiddenbrain.org。感谢您对与我们合作的兴趣。这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantham。在任何旅程中，总有一些时刻会让人觉得漫长得没有尽头。你每天去上班，做着同样的工作。
Meet the same people. At home, you wash the dishes, clean the bedroom, do the laundry. On weekends, you watch the same TV shows, go for the same walks, talk to the same relatives. One day starts to look like the next. Weeks blur into each other. And then you start to wonder, what am I really doing? Where am I headed? Am I making any progress at all?
见到同样的人。在家里，你洗碗、打扫卧室、洗衣服。周末，你看同样的电视节目，去同样的地方散步，和同样的亲戚聊天。一天开始变得和另一天没什么两样。几周的时间模糊在一起。然后你开始怀疑，我到底在做什么？我要去向何方？我真的有取得任何进展吗？
We have different names for this phenomenon. Writers say they are blocked. office workers talk about being in a rut. People of a certain age call it a midlife crisis. But they are all different ways of saying, I'm stuck. This feeling of stuckness can be a particularly big impediment when it comes to making progress on longstanding goals.
我们对这种现象有不同的称呼。作家说他们遇到了瓶颈，上班族说自己陷入了死循环，特定年龄段的人称之为中年危机。但这些都是在表达同一种意思：我被困住了。这种被困住的感觉，在实现长期目标时，可能是一个特别大的障碍。
There are few things as demotivating as a feeling that no matter how hard you try, you never seem to get where you want to go. Today, we bring you the latest episode in our U2.0 series about the mental obstacles that can get in the way of our goals and resolutions. We're going to explore how even the most talented and driven people can find themselves in a rut, and what research suggests is the best way to get out of one of these emotional troughs. How we get stuck and powerful insights into how to get unstuck this week on Hidden Brain.
没有什么比这种感觉更让人丧失动力了：无论你多么努力，似乎永远无法到达你想去的地方。今天，我们为您带来U2.0系列的最新一集，探讨阻碍我们实现目标和决心的心理障碍。我们将探讨即使是最有天赋和动力的人，是如何陷入困境的，以及研究表明摆脱这种情绪低谷的最佳方法是什么。本周的Hidden Brain，我们将探讨我们是如何被困住的，并提供关于如何摆脱困境的深刻见解。
All of us have had moments in our lives when we feel stuck. We don't know what we want to do. or if we do know what we want, we don't know how to do it. At New York University, psychologist Adam Alter studies the science of how to get unstuck. Adam Alter, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much, Shankar. Adam, I want to play you a clip from a very dramatic and popular TV series.
我们每个人在生活中都有过感到被困住的时刻。我们不知道自己想做什么，或者即使知道自己想要什么，也不知道该怎么做。在纽约大学，心理学家Adam Alter研究了如何摆脱困境的科学。Adam Alter，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢，Shankar。Adam，我想给你播放一段非常戏剧性且受欢迎的电视剧片段。
This is from the Season 7 trailer of Game of Thrones. The centuries our families fought together against their common enemy. Despite their differences together. We need to do the same if we're going to survive. Because the enemy is real. It's always been real. Now, Adam, you've spent some time thinking about this because even as the TV show is wildly dramatic and packed with action,
这是《权力的游戏》第七季的预告片。几个世纪以来，我们的家族为了共同的敌人并肩作战。尽管有分歧，但为了生存，我们必须团结一致。因为敌人是真实的。它一直都是真实的。现在，Adam，你花了一些时间思考这个问题，因为尽管这部电视剧非常戏剧化且充满动作场面，
something very curious was happening to the writer of the series. Tell me how George R.R. Martin started writing this epic fantasy. And what happened along the way? Well, he started very successfully. He wrote a number of books in the series and the gap between those books grew larger and larger to the point where he experienced what he described as profound writer's block. And he's expressed great puzzlement because he was so productive for so long, but now says in interviews, I don't really have an explanation for you. I know you as fans of the series are looking for the next installment. It's been many years. I just don't know
但该剧的作者身上发生了一件非常奇怪的事情。告诉我们George R.R. Martin是如何开始创作这部史诗奇幻作品的，以及在此过程中发生了什么？嗯，他开始得非常成功。他写了该系列中的几本书，但这些书之间的间隔越来越长，以至于他经历了所谓的严重的写作瓶颈。他对此感到非常困惑，因为他长期以来一直非常高产，但现在在采访中说，我真的无法向你解释。我知道作为该系列的粉丝，你们都在期待下一部作品。已经过去很多年了。我只是不知道
what to say. I just haven't been able to produce it. And that's where we sit now. So fans of the books are waiting for the next installment to be released, even as the TV show itself has been completed. In an interview in 2018, he said, I know there are a lot of people out there who are very angry with me that Winds of Winter, this is the sixth volume out of seven, isn't finished. And I'm mad about that myself. I wish I finished it four years ago. I wish it was finished now, but it's not. but I've had dark nights of the soul where I've pounded my head against the keyboard and said, God, will I ever finish this?
该说什么。我只是无法写出来。这就是我们现在的处境。所以书迷们正在等待下一部的出版，尽管电视剧本身已经完结。在2018年的一次采访中，他说，我知道外面有很多人对我非常生气，因为《凛冬的寒风》（七卷中的第六卷）还没有完成。我自己也为此感到愤怒。我希望我四年前就完成了它。我希望它现在已经完成了，但事实并非如此。但我经历过灵魂的黑暗之夜，我曾对着键盘捶打自己的头，说，上帝啊，我还能完成它吗？
The show is going further and further forward. He's talking here about Game of Thrones and I'm falling further and further behind. What the hell is happening here? And you can almost hear his own mystification about his own block here, Adam. He's very distressed. Yeah, it's interesting when you see someone
剧集正在不断向前推进。他在这里谈论的是《权力的游戏》，而我却越来越落后。这到底是怎么回事？Adam，你几乎可以听到他对自己这种瓶颈的困惑。他非常痛苦。是的，当你看到一个人
who is such a colossal talent for writing these kinds of stories. And yet still, we're not talking about being stuck for a day or a week or a month, we're talking about a matter of many years, and he has no idea what he's supposed to be doing moving forward. So it's a very profound case of stuckness. So you say that George R.R. Martin and people like him might have something to learn from an experiment conducted many years ago by the psychologist Clark Hull. What makes this experiment unusual is that the test subjects were mice? Yeah, that's right. Hull was a behaviorist, and a lot of behaviorists in that period in the middle of the 20th century studied mice because they were
拥有如此巨大的天赋来创作这类故事时，这很有趣。然而，我们谈论的不是被困住一天、一周或一个月，而是长达数年的时间，他完全不知道接下来该做什么。所以这是一个非常深刻的被困案例。你说George R.R. Martin和像他这样的人，或许可以从心理学家Clark Hull多年前进行的一项实验中得到一些启示。这个实验的不同寻常之处在于，测试对象是老鼠？是的，没错。Hull是一位行为主义者，那个时期（20世纪中叶）的许多行为主义者研究老鼠，因为它们
very easy to study. They were very interested in some very basic psychological principles that applied to mice just as they did to humans. And so Hull used to create mazes for his mice and he would watch as they completed these mazes. What do mice running through a maze have to do with a writer of epic fantasy novels getting stuck? The thing that he noticed most was that the mice when they first entered the maze were quite slow to move. They were puzzled by the situation that faced them. But as the goal, whatever the goal was, whether it was a piece of food or whether it was exiting the maze, as the goal came into view, they moved much more quickly. And he described this as the goal gradient. It's the idea that at least subjectively,
非常容易研究。他们对适用于老鼠和人类的一些基本心理学原理非常感兴趣。因此，Hull过去常为他的老鼠制造迷宫，并观察它们完成迷宫的过程。老鼠跑迷宫与史诗奇幻小说作家遇到瓶颈有什么关系？他注意到最重要的一点是，老鼠刚进入迷宫时移动得相当缓慢。它们对所面临的情况感到困惑。但当目标出现时，无论是食物还是迷宫出口，随着目标进入视野，它们移动得快多了。他将其描述为目标梯度。这是一种观点，至少在主观上，
it feels to mice and actually to humans as well, as though as you can see the goal in sight, that the experience becomes almost metaphorically downhill. It's much easier to to bridge the gap between where you are and where you'd like to be. And I think all of us have had this experience in one form or the other. You know, you feel like the end is in sight, whether you're a runner and you can see the finish tape inside. It does give you a bit of a spurt to get to the finish line. But talk a minute about this goal gradient idea because there's something really interesting that happens here at the start, the middle, and at the end.
对于老鼠，实际上对于人类来说也是如此，当你看到目标在望时，这种体验在隐喻上几乎变成了下坡路。弥合你所在位置和你想要到达位置之间的差距要容易得多。我想我们所有人都以某种形式有过这种体验。你知道，当你觉得终点在望时，无论你是一名跑步者，还是能看到终点线，这确实会给你一点冲刺到终点线的动力。但请谈谈这个目标梯度的概念，因为在开始、中间和结束时，确实发生了一些非常有趣的事情。
What happens, Adam? Yeah, so the original idea that Hull described was that we're much quicker closer to the goal, But subsequent research has shown that it's a bit more complicated than that. That actually we slow down dramatically in the middle when we're sort of unmoored. We're somewhere between the beginning of the goal and the end of the goal. And so we move quickly at the beginning because we have a bit of motivation. We're fresh. We're ready to go.
发生了什么，Adam？是的，Hull描述的最初观点是，我们离目标越近，速度就越快，但随后的研究表明，情况要复杂一些。实际上，当我们在中间阶段，也就是处于一种无所适从的状态时，我们的速度会大幅下降。我们处于目标开始和结束之间的某个位置。所以我们在开始时移动得很快，因为我们有一点动力。我们精力充沛，准备出发。
And we slow down in the middle. And then as we get to the end of the process, we speed up again as the goal comes within view. So it's a sort of you shape. You go quickly, then slowly, then quickly again. Adam says it is revealing that George R.R. Martin got stuck as he was slogging his way through the series. The end of the series was some distance away, while the start of the project was in the distant past. There's lots of evidence that the gold gradient effect plays a powerful role in many dimensions of our lives. There are some studies that show that it applies to physical activity, but it applies just as much to mental activity as well.
然后在中间阶段我们慢了下来。接着，当我们接近过程的终点时，随着目标进入视野，我们再次加速。所以这是一种U型曲线。你走得很快，然后变慢，然后再变快。Adam说，George R.R. Martin在创作系列过程中陷入困境是很有启示意义的。系列终点还很遥远，而项目开始已是遥远的过去。有大量证据表明，目标梯度效应在我们生活的许多方面都发挥着重要作用。有一些研究表明，它适用于体育活动，但也同样适用于心理活动。
So there were some studies that were run asking people, for example, one of my colleagues, Andrea Bernetzi and his colleagues asked people to find words within words. So he would give them a long word and then he would say how many shorter English words can you find within the letters of this longer word. And he did that nine times. And what he found was that people were slowest around the fifth attempt, much slower than around the first or second or eighth or ninth attempts. And so this applies just as much in his studies to mental activities, where there's
所以有一些研究要求人们，例如，我的同事Andrea Bernetzi和他的同事要求人们在单词中寻找单词。他会给他们一个长单词，然后说你能在这些字母中找到多少个较短的英语单词。他做了九次。他发现人们在第五次尝试时最慢，比第一次、第二次、第八次或第九次尝试要慢得多。因此，这在他的研究中同样适用于心理活动，即
some motivation required as it does to physical activities. I understand this is also true when it comes to paying off credit card debt. You make a good start at the beginning, and if you get close to the end, you feel like you have a sport to finish off, but the middle is really difficult again. That's right. Yeah, there's quite a lot of research on the financial implications of this stuck-in-the-middle effect, as it's known, that shows exactly that we pay off credit card debt quickly, then slowly, then quickly.
需要一些动力，就像它适用于体育活动一样。我明白这在偿还信用卡债务时也是如此。你在开始时有一个好的开端，如果你接近终点，你会觉得有动力去完成它，但中间阶段又变得非常困难。没错。是的，关于这种所谓的“中间困境”效应的财务影响，有相当多的研究表明，情况确实如此：我们偿还信用卡债务的速度是先快，后慢，再快。
when we're donating to charities, you see something similar. We donate much more readily, and we donate larger amounts at the beginning when the charity first makes the solicitation. And then again, as the charity reaches its goal or approaches its goal, we donate again. But in the middle process, say the charity is looking for $100,000, around that $50,000 mark, you see a slowdown collectively in how much people give. So you argue that one of the reasons that the middle of a project is so challenging, is that there are fewer and fewer landmarks to mark our progress. And you've compared the journey we take on a long project
当我们向慈善机构捐款时，也会看到类似的情况。我们在慈善机构最初发出募捐请求时，捐款更积极，金额也更大。然后，当慈善机构达到或接近其目标时，我们再次捐款。但在中间过程中，假设慈善机构正在寻求10万美元，在5万美元左右的关口，你会看到人们的捐款速度集体放缓。所以你认为，项目中间阶段之所以如此具有挑战性，原因之一是标记我们进展的里程碑越来越少。你把我们在长期项目中的旅程比作
to the experience of a sailor on a ship traveling across the Atlantic Ocean from the United States to Britain. Explain that analogy, Adam. Yeah, so when you leave, imagine you're sailing from New York to, say, Southampton in Britain. When you leave, you have a number of landmarks behind you and that, you know, there's a lot of activity at the beginning of that journey,
一名水手乘坐船只横跨大西洋从美国前往英国的经历。解释一下这个类比，Adam。好的，想象一下你正从纽约航行到英国的南安普敦。当你离开时，你身后有许多地标，你知道，在旅程的开始阶段有很多活动，
things that suggest that you're moving, you can see how fast you're moving. And when you get into the middle part of that journey, all you see is ocean. But you don't have any external cues that tell you how fast you're moving. And so that middle period is a long period between leaving the land behind and then waiting for the next bit of land to come into view. And so during that period, in contrast to the beginning of the experience, you don't have a lot of feedback about your progress.
这表明你正在移动，你可以看到你的移动速度有多快。当你进入旅程的中间部分时，你看到的只有海洋。你没有任何外部线索来告诉你移动得有多快。因此，中间这段时期是离开陆地后，等待下一块陆地进入视野之间的漫长时期。所以在这段时间里，与体验的开始相比，你没有关于进展的反馈。
And that's demotivating. It gives you the sense that you're not really making progress, even if you're moving quite rapidly. And then of course, as you approach Britain again, you see land, you might see parts of the British Isles, and again, you can start to see how fast you're moving, and you're getting some external cues that are reinforcing. They say keep going, you're almost there. And I think that's how a lot of our goals function. We have that middle period that can often be quite expansive, where we just have no sense that we're making progress, and so that's greatly demotivating. So is one solution then to try and create more landmarks in the middle?
这会让人丧失动力。即使你移动得相当快，它也会让你觉得你并没有真正取得进展。当然，当你再次接近英国时，你看到了陆地，你可能会看到不列颠群岛的部分地区，同样，你可以开始看到你的移动速度有多快，并且你得到了一些强化的外部线索。它们在说继续前进，你快到了。我认为这就是我们许多目标运作的方式。我们有那个中间阶段，它通常可能非常漫长，我们根本感觉不到自己在取得进展，所以这非常令人沮丧。那么，一个解决方案是尝试在中间创造更多的里程碑吗？
I think so. I think it's to shrink the middle as far as possible, and there are different ways to do that. In the case of sailing, there aren't that many options, but what you want to do is to give yourself some sort of feedback that suggests that you're making progress. And so you might create sub-goals. Instead of thinking of the journey as a single goal from start to finish, you might say, well, you know, I've got this map that I'm using to navigate through the Atlantic Ocean. I know when I hit certain latitude or longitudinal measures, I know that I've reached a certain person. of the way. And that's obviously much easier to do when you're engaged in some sort of activity, whether it's running or whether it's some sort of mental activity. You just kind of shrink the goal down. You bracket it much more narrowly. So you have these smaller subgoals. So runners often say, you know, my goal is to run the next mile or the next half mile or even,
我想是的。我认为是要尽可能地缩短中间阶段，有不同的方法可以做到这一点。在航海的情况下，选择并不多，但你想做的是给自己某种反馈，表明你正在取得进展。所以你可以创造子目标。与其把旅程看作从开始到结束的单一目标，你可能会说，好吧，你知道，我有这张地图，我用它来在大西洋中航行。我知道当我到达特定的纬度或经度测量值时，我知道我已经到达了某个阶段。这显然在从事某种活动时更容易做到，无论是跑步还是某种心理活动。你只是把目标缩小了。你把它限定得更窄。所以你有这些更小的子目标。所以跑步者经常说，你知道，我的目标是跑完下一英里或下一半英里，甚至，
you know, as far as my eye can see and you set a target and you run to that target and then you look at another target and you run to that target. And it's the same principle again. You're trying to be ending the race all the time. Exactly. Yeah, you're sort of atomizing the goal. You're turning it into its most basic elements. And at the very extreme point, if you have ever run and feel that you're really struggling, it becomes a matter of taking one step at a time. You know, each step is its own little goal and you get your own little burst of positive feedback with each step. I understand that you have employed a similar insight when it comes to writing. What does that look like, Adam? Yeah, so, you know, writing is very similar. If you're writing something,
你知道，只要我的眼睛能看到的地方，你设定一个目标，然后跑到那个目标，然后再看另一个目标，再跑到那个目标。这又是同样的原则。你一直在试图结束比赛。没错。是的，你是在把目标原子化。你把它变成了最基本的要素。在最极端的情况下，如果你曾经跑步并感到非常挣扎，它就变成了一次迈出一步的问题。你知道，每一步都是它自己的小目标，每一步你都会得到一点点积极的反馈。我明白你在写作时也采用了类似的见解。那是什么样的，Adam？是的，你知道，写作非常相似。如果你正在写东西，
large like a thesis or a book or an article, there are different ways to construe that goal. Now, obviously, if you zoom back far enough, the goal is to finish the book or finish the article, but that's overwhelming in the same way that sailing a ship across the ocean might be overwhelming. And so you might have this stuck in the middle experience, which I think a lot of people do. The nice thing about writing a book is it's broken naturally into chapters. So already you've shrunk those middles down, let's say there are 12 chapters in a book that you're writing. you've taken that large goal and you've made sure that the middle is smaller by having these 12 sub-goals that fall under that larger umbrella. But even within a chapter, you know, people will say
像论文、书籍或文章这样的大型目标，解读这些目标的方式有很多种。当然，如果你把视野放得足够远，目标就是完成这本书或这篇文章，但这就像驾驶一艘船横渡大洋一样，让人感到不知所措。因此，你可能会有这种陷入中间阶段的体验，我想很多人都有过。写书的好处在于它自然地分成了若干章节。所以你已经缩小了那些中间过程，假设你正在写的书有12章。你已经把那个宏大的目标拆解，通过这12个从属于大目标的子目标，确保了中间过程变得更小。但即使是在一章之内，你知道，人们会说
every hundred words is my goal. And I've often used that tactic, especially as the process of writing becomes difficult or when you're entering a difficult part of a story or a study that you're trying to describe, what I find is that the goal for me shrinks as I am struggling more as I become more stuck and it grows again as the process of writing feels a bit easier. And I find that shrinking and expanding happens constantly as I'm writing the book. I understand that you sometimes set the timer on your watch for 60 seconds and aim to write until the timer goes off. Why would you set a timer to write for only one minute? Yeah, these are the most desperate moments, right? You don't want to write for a minute and think about that as the height of what you're trying to achieve. You
我的目标是每写一百个字。我经常使用这种策略，特别是在写作过程变得困难，或者当你进入故事或研究中难以描述的部分时。我发现，当我越挣扎、越卡壳时，我的目标就会缩小；而当写作过程感觉稍微容易一些时，目标又会扩大。我发现这种缩小和扩大的过程在我写书时不断发生。我了解到你有时会在手表上设置60秒的计时器，并目标在计时器响起前一直写作。为什么要设置一个只有一分钟的写作计时器呢？是的，这些是最绝望的时刻，对吧？你不会想只写一分钟，并认为这就是你所能达到的最高成就。你
obviously want to do much more than that. But there are moments when writing is incredibly difficult in the same way that George R.R.R. Martin describes it where any writing is a small victory. And so what you can do is just as a runner might say every step is a little victory, you might say that writing for 60 seconds or even 15 or 30 seconds, if you're very desperate, is its own goal. And the idea behind that is trying to lubricate whatever machinery is required to write for 10 minutes and then an hour and then three and five and so on. And I find that works pretty well because there's a lot of inertia in a lot of these processes that are goal-based, where once you get the ball rolling, things seem to improve, but getting the ball rolling can be really difficult. And the best way to do that is to lower the bar as far as possible, so it's barely above the ground.
显然想做得更多。但有些时候，写作变得极其困难，就像乔治·R·R·马丁所描述的那样，任何写作都是一次小小的胜利。所以你可以做的是，就像跑步者可能会说每一步都是一次小胜利一样，你也可以说，写60秒，甚至如果你非常绝望的话，写15或30秒，本身就是一个目标。其背后的想法是试图润滑写作所需的任何机制，先写10分钟，然后一小时，再到三小时、五小时，以此类推。我发现这很有效，因为很多基于目标的流程都有很大的惯性，一旦你让球滚动起来，事情似乎就会好转，但让球滚动起来可能非常困难。最好的方法就是尽可能降低门槛，让它几乎贴近地面。
And I think many people notice this, you know, when there's a deadline looming, suddenly people start working much faster. And then right as they approach the deadline, they sort of say, you know, I have all these ideas bursting at my head right now. now, if I could only have another half an hour, I could get a lot of it down. And so what you're basically saying is take advantage of that and create artificial deadlines in order to get yourself jump started. Yeah, that's exactly right. And I think by constraining yourself, either by a deadline or by saying I'm only going to write for a minute, something about that process of constraining yourself is paradoxically liberating. A lot of the extraneous material that might have been weighing on our minds and sapping limited mental resources goes by the wayside. What's left is, you know,
我想很多人都注意到了这一点，你知道，当截止日期临近时，人们突然开始工作得快多了。就在他们接近截止日期时，他们会说，你知道，我现在脑子里涌现出所有这些想法。如果我能再多半小时，我就能把很多东西写下来。所以你基本上是在说，利用这一点，创造人为的截止日期来让自己启动。是的，完全正确。我认为通过限制自己，无论是通过截止日期，还是通过说我只写一分钟，这种限制自己的过程在某种程度上是反直觉地解放了自己。很多可能一直压在我们心头、消耗我们有限心理资源的无关紧要的东西都被抛弃了。剩下的就是，你知道，
is just this real sense of sudden clarity, which I've always found really inspires great ideas and inspires a lot of activity, especially when I feel stuck. The middle of any extended project can be a trap. Becoming aware of this fact can help us prepare for the trap and to make plans to unstick ourselves. But of course, the middle of projects is not the only reason people get stuck. There are lots of other drivers,
就是这种突然的清晰感，我一直觉得这真的能激发伟大的想法，并激发大量的活动，特别是在我感到卡住的时候。任何长期项目的中间阶段都可能是一个陷阱。意识到这一事实可以帮助我们为陷阱做好准备，并制定计划让自己摆脱困境。但当然，项目的中间阶段并不是人们卡住的唯一原因。还有很多其他的驱动因素，
and it turns out we create many of the problems ourselves. When we come back, how we get in our own way and how to get out. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Adam Alter is a psychologist at New York University. He has studied why we get stuck and how we can get ourselves unstuck. One thing he and others have found is that many of the obstacles that stand between us and our goals are created by us. Adam, in your book, Inademy of a Breakthrough, you illustrate one of these obstacles with a story about a musician.
事实证明，很多问题是我们自己造成的。回来后，我们将探讨我们是如何阻碍自己的，以及如何摆脱这种困境。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。亚当·奥尔特是纽约大学的一位心理学家。他研究了我们为什么会卡住以及如何让自己摆脱困境。他和其他人发现的一件事是，许多阻碍我们实现目标的障碍都是我们自己制造的。亚当，在你的书《突破的解剖学》中，你用一个关于音乐家的故事说明了其中一个障碍。
I want to play you a clip of a song. Adam, tell me Jeff Tweedy's Story and the trap he once constructed for himself. So Tweedy is the front man of the band Wilco, and he's a bit of a renaissance man. He writes music, but he also writes books. And he has described quite vividly his own experiences with writers' block in both contexts and talked quite a lot about how he's managed to unstick himself over time. One problem that Jeff Tweedy has battled will be familiar to many people. Perfectionism.
我想给你播放一段歌曲片段。亚当，告诉我们杰夫·特威迪的故事以及他曾经为自己设下的陷阱。特威迪是Wilco乐队的主唱，他算是一个博学多才的人。他创作音乐，但也写书。他非常生动地描述了自己在两种语境下经历的写作障碍，并谈了很多关于他如何随着时间的推移让自己摆脱困境的经历。杰夫·特威迪所抗争的一个问题，很多人都会感到熟悉。完美主义。
Perfectionism is paralyzing because what it basically does, is it signals to you that unless you're producing perfection, you're failing. And so the feedback that you're getting constantly, since most of us aren't perfect most of the time, is negative feedback. And it's demotivating. And it also means that when you ask yourself at the end of a period, whether it's a few hours or at the end of a day, whether you've produced anything, because perfectionism is essentially binary, the feedback you get is that you have failed most days or many days. And so people like Tweedy who have created this trap for themselves find that it's very, very hard to be motivated across time.
完美主义是令人瘫痪的，因为它基本上是在向你发出信号：除非你做到完美，否则你就是在失败。因此，你不断得到的反馈——因为我们大多数人大部分时间并不完美——都是负面反馈。这会让人失去动力。这也意味着，当你在一阶段结束时，无论是几个小时还是一天结束时，问自己是否产出了什么东西，因为完美主义本质上是二元的，你得到的反馈就是你在大多数日子或很多日子里都失败了。所以像特威迪这样为自己制造了这个陷阱的人，发现随着时间的推移，保持动力是非常非常困难的。
And so the products they create are few and far between, and then they often feel quite negative about what they've created. So you say that Jeff Tweedy has come up with an ingenious way of battling this challenge. What does he do? Yeah, he has this great description, this term, he says he pours out the bad material. So the way he thinks about it, and I think this is true of a lot of creative enterprises, is the obvious stuff is stuff that's not particularly novel or interesting, And that's the stuff that sits at the top of your head.
因此，他们创造的产品寥寥无几，而且他们往往对自己创造的东西感觉相当负面。所以你说杰夫·特威迪想出了一种巧妙的方法来应对这个挑战。他做了什么？是的，他有一个很棒的描述，这个术语，他说他要“倒掉坏材料”。所以他思考的方式，我认为这适用于许多创意企业，就是显而易见的东西通常不是特别新颖或有趣，而这些东西就堆在你的脑海里。
And what you've got to do is if you imagine that all your ideas are essentially liquids sitting one on top of the other, you've got to pour out the bad stuff. And that's what Tweety describes. He wakes up in the morning and he says, I've got to pour out the bad material. And what's incredibly liberating about that in contrast to perfectionism is this idea that you expect that to be mediocre. And that's okay because the way you think about it is you're getting the bad stuff out of the way so the good stuff can emerge.
你需要做的是，如果你想象你所有的想法本质上是堆叠在一起的液体，你必须把坏的东西倒掉。这就是特威迪所描述的。他早上醒来，说：“我必须倒掉坏材料。”与完美主义相比，这种做法极其令人解放，因为它包含了一个想法，即你预期这些东西是平庸的。这没关系，因为你思考的方式是，你正在把坏东西清理掉，这样好东西才能浮现出来。
And so I understand he deliberately sometimes tries to pour out bad stuff. He tries to come up with bad stuff, so the good stuff can then emerge? Yeah, the nice thing about removing all requirements for quality is that quantity rises. And so if being unstuck is about moving forward, the idea that you don't care about quality, but you care only about something coming out, anything coming out, means that you get into this really great habit of actually making some progress later on. and by even trying to write bad songs, he finds that that shows him what's good, because by making something bad, if you're as successful and as talented as he is,
所以我理解他有时会故意尝试倒掉坏东西。他试图想出坏东西，这样好东西才能随之浮现？是的，消除所有质量要求的好处在于数量会上升。所以，如果摆脱困境意味着前进，那么你不关心质量，只关心有东西产出，任何东西产出，就意味着你养成了一个非常好的习惯，即在以后真正取得一些进展。而且通过尝试写烂歌，他发现这向他展示了什么是好的，因为通过制造出糟糕的东西，如果你像他一样成功且有才华，
it shows you something about what you're not looking for, and then later on you use that as a sort of contrast point, and you produce better material. You argue that perfectionism is an aspect of a larger tendency we have, which is to understand goal pursuit in moral terms. What do you mean by this, Adam? Yeah, I think people who succeed seem in some moral sense to be better than those who fail. And I think that's tied to the idea that from hard work comes success.
它会向你展示一些你不是在寻找的东西，然后稍后你将其用作一种对比点，从而产出更好的材料。你认为完美主义是我们拥有一种更大倾向的一个方面，即以道德术语来理解目标追求。亚当，你这是什么意思？是的，我认为那些成功的人在某种道德意义上似乎比那些失败的人更好。我认为这与“成功源于努力工作”的观念有关。
And so if you're constantly failing, perhaps you're not working hard enough, perhaps you're not capitalizing on whatever talents you might have and so on. And so there's a strong moral dimension to not succeeding. I mean, it's also the case that I think many of us equate goals with self-respect. So if we don't reach a goal, we feel like we've lost respect for ourselves. Yeah, that's right. humans as a species are completionists. It's very important to us to finish things, even if the exercise is futile. And so this idea of finishing something you start has a strong moral element to it.
所以如果你不断失败，也许是因为你不够努力，也许是因为你没有利用好你可能拥有的任何天赋等等。因此，不成功有着强烈的道德维度。我的意思是，我认为我们许多人也将目标等同于自尊。所以如果我们没有达到目标，我们就会觉得我们失去了对自己的尊重。是的，没错。人类作为一个物种是“完成主义者”。完成事情对我们来说非常重要，即使这项工作是徒劳的。因此，完成你开始的事情这个想法具有强烈的道德色彩。
When we turn ordinary goals into moral causes, we switch from being what social scientists call satisfacers to maximizers. Instead of asking if what we have accomplished is good enough, we adopt all-or-nothing thinking. If you decide you want to run a marathon in under three hours and finish the race in three hours and ten minutes, this extraordinary feat of human endurance gets counted as a failure. If you want to write five articles in the course of a year but only manage four, this means you've fallen short. If you decide you want to save a thousand dollars more in a savings account, putting away $880 can leave you feeling disappointed. Thinking this way can contribute to a feeling of being stuck, or what Adam calls stuckness.
当我们把普通目标变成道德事业时，我们就从社会科学家所说的“满足者”转变成了“最大化者”。我们不再问我们所取得的成就是否足够好，而是采取非黑即白的思维。如果你决定要在三小时内跑完马拉松，结果以三小时十分钟跑完，这种非凡的人类耐力壮举就被算作失败。如果你想在一年内写五篇文章，但只完成了四篇，这意味着你没达标。如果你决定要在储蓄账户里多存一千美元，存入880美元会让你感到失望。这种思维方式会导致一种被卡住的感觉，或者亚当所说的“卡住状态”。
Yeah, those round numbers are really dangerous in all those contexts because they form artificial goals that we, I say, fetishize. And I think that's an accurate description because it's something that we take so seriously that really becomes a legitimate goal for us. One of the other things that you and other researchers have found is that many of us have a tendency to focus on our own struggles while imagining that others have it easy. Talk about how this causes us to become stuck at him. Yeah, I did some research. and basically found that everyone essentially in at least one respect is stuck, but they also say that it feels very lonely and they imagine that they're the only ones in that position, which is a really interesting finding that even though we're all standing next to
是的，那些整数在所有这些语境下都非常危险，因为它们形成了我们——我说——“恋物化”的人为目标。我认为这是一个准确的描述，因为我们太认真地对待它，以至于它真的成为了我们合法的目标。你和其他研究人员发现的另一件事是，我们许多人倾向于关注自己的挣扎，同时想象别人过得很轻松。谈谈这如何导致我们被卡住，亚当。是的，我做了一些研究，基本上发现每个人在至少一个方面都是卡住的，但他们也说这感觉非常孤独，他们想象自己是唯一处于那种境地的人，这是一个非常有趣的发现，即使我们都站在
each other with these partitions, we don't know what other people are thinking. Stuckness is often hidden from view. And so we sort of imagine that it's just us facing those particular headwinds, whereas if you had the conversation with other people, you realize that we're all going through something. And that's a really liberating experience when you actually do open up that conversation channel. But even worse than not having conversations about the ways in which we're all stuck, we do have conversations about each other's successes. I mean, on social media, you hear about people, you know, getting jobs or getting gigs or, you know, winning awards
彼此身边，中间隔着隔板，我们不知道别人在想什么。卡住状态通常是隐藏在视线之外的。所以我们有点想象只有我们自己面临那些特定的逆风，而如果你和其他人进行对话，你会意识到我们都在经历一些事情。当你真正打开那个对话渠道时，这是一种非常令人解放的体验。但比不谈论我们都被卡住的方式更糟糕的是，我们确实会谈论彼此的成功。我的意思是，在社交媒体上，你听说人们，你知道，找到工作或获得演出机会，或者，你知道，赢得奖项
or, you know, good things happening to them. And of course, even if those good things actually are happening on a relatively rare basis, that's mostly what we hear. And the success, stories end up clouding our impression of what's happening in our lives versus the lives of other people? What people are doing on social media is they are sharing the very best 1% of their lives and keeping the other 99% the part that's complicated or messy or that involves stuckness or whatever they term failure from social media for obvious reasons. And so what you end up experiencing, if you're spending one or two or three or four hours a day on these platforms, is you're experiencing everyone else's successes. And that throws into stark relief how different you're
或者，你知道，好事发生在他们身上。当然，即使这些好事确实是在相对罕见的基础上发生的，那也是我们听到的大部分内容。而成功故事最终模糊了我们对生活中正在发生的事情与其他人生活中正在发生的事情的印象？人们在社交媒体上所做的是，他们分享了他们生活中最美好的1%，而将剩下的99%——那些复杂或混乱的部分，或者涉及卡住状态或他们称之为失败的部分——出于显而易见的原因从社交媒体上隐藏起来。所以，如果你每天花一到四个小时在这些平台上，你最终体验到的是其他所有人的成功。这与你自己的生活形成了鲜明的对比，
life is where the other 99% is real and present and concrete for you. And that doesn't involve success all the time. Psychologists have a name for this phenomenon where we all walk around thinking the same thing, but believe we are the only ones having those thoughts. They call it pluralistic ignorance. Yeah, it's a psychological phenomenon where your experience of the world feels very lonely because your understanding of the way other people experience the world is quite different. And it usually happens when the thing we're talking, about is hidden from view. It only exists in your head. So the classic research on this topic looked at drinking on college campuses. And what the research has found was that when people as individuals
你的生活中，那剩下的99%是真实、存在且具体的。而且那并不总是涉及成功。心理学家有一个名字来称呼这种现象，即我们所有人都走来走去，想着同样的事情，却相信自己是唯一有这些想法的人。他们称之为“多元无知”。是的，这是一种心理现象，你对世界的体验感觉非常孤独，因为你对其他人体验世界方式的理解是非常不同的。而且它通常发生在我们谈论的事情被隐藏在视线之外时。它只存在于你的脑海中。所以关于这个话题的经典研究观察了大学校园里的饮酒情况。研究发现，当人们作为个体
report how they feel about drinking on campus, these are college students, they basically say, I think in general we probably all drink a little bit more than we should on campus. Some say we drink much more than we should. But I think everyone else thinks that the drinking is fine. And so that's just the norm, and I deviate from the norm by thinking we're drinking too much. But actually, when you ask each individual person, the same thing comes up time and time again. Everyone says the same thing. I think we're drinking a little bit too much, but I think everyone else thinks it's fine. The reason they think it's fine is because all you see is the behavior of other people, which is that they're all drinking a huge amount. And the same thing happens with stuckness,
报告他们对校园饮酒的感受时，这些是大学生，他们基本上说，我认为总的来说，我们可能在校园里都喝得比应该喝的稍微多一点。有些人说我们喝得比应该喝的多得多。但我认为其他人认为饮酒没问题。所以这只是常态，而我通过认为我们喝得太多而偏离了常态。但实际上，当你询问每一个个体时，同样的事情会一次又一次地出现。每个人都说同样的话。我认为我们喝得稍微多了一点，但我认为其他人认为这没问题。他们认为没问题的原因是，你所看到的只是其他人的行为，即他们都喝了大量的酒。同样的事情也发生在卡住状态上，
that all you see is people making their ways through the world, but what you experience from your own perspective is something quite different, which is that there are a lot of sticking points along the way. And they are very, very prominent and very concrete for you and very visible and salient, but they are hidden when they apply to other people. And so you get that same sense of pluralistic ignorance. And in some ways, this speaks to the solution then for this pluralistic ignorance, which is when you feel like you are alone in being stuck, it's really important to actually resist the impulse to withdraw into yourself and actually try and reach out to others. Yeah, I think in any case of pluralistic ignorance arises only because there's a gap between what you experience and what you perceive in other people.
你所看到的只是人们在世界上前行，但从你自己的角度体验到的却完全不同，那就是一路上有很多卡住的点。它们对你来说非常、非常突出，非常具体，非常可见且显著，但当它们适用于其他人时，它们就被隐藏起来了。所以你得到了同样的“多元无知”感。在某种程度上，这说明了解决这种多元无知的方法，那就是当你觉得自己在被卡住时感到孤独，真正重要的是要抵制退缩到自己内心的冲动，并真正尝试去接触他人。是的，我认为任何多元无知的情况产生，仅仅是因为你的体验和你对其他人的感知之间存在差距。
And the only way to break down that gap is to ask whether people in their own heads are experiencing what you're experiencing. And very, very often the answer will be yes. There is another way we get in our own way. It's when we assume that progress towards our goals involves following a straight line. Either you are proceeding down the path and making headway or you're off track. But in reality, a long journey is rarely a linear path. This self-inflicted wound turns out to be a problem, especially in countries like the United States. Yeah, this actually goes back to some of the early research I did as a graduate student.
而打破这种差距的唯一方法是询问人们在他们自己的脑海中是否正在经历你所经历的事情。而且非常、非常经常，答案会是肯定的。我们阻碍自己的另一种方式是，当我们假设朝着目标前进涉及遵循一条直线时。要么你正在沿着路径前进并取得进展，要么你偏离了轨道。但实际上，漫长的旅程很少是一条直线。这种自残的伤口被证明是一个问题，特别是在像美国这样的国家。是的，这实际上回到了我作为研究生时所做的一些早期研究。
I was very interested in how different cultures perceive change. And what I discovered is that in the West, countries like the United States, we tend to experience change as rare. We don't think it happens all that often. And we tend to think of things as linear. And so in some studies I gave people some stock charts and asked them to predict how the stock was going to perform. Some of those stocks had done well in the past and they tended to think they'd continue to do well. Some had done poorly. They expected them to continue to do poorly.
我对不同文化如何感知变化非常感兴趣。我发现，在西方，像美国这样的国家，我们倾向于认为变化是罕见的。我们不认为它经常发生。而且我们倾向于认为事物是线性的。所以，在一些研究中，我给人们看了一些股票图表，并要求他们预测股票的表现。其中一些股票在过去表现良好，他们倾向于认为它们会继续表现良好。一些表现不佳。他们预计它们会继续表现不佳。
Or I'd give them some weather charts and I'd say, hey, it's been sunny 10 days in a row. What are you think is going to happen tomorrow? They would predict more sun. Or if it had been raining, they predicted more rain. But in the east, in Korea, in Japan, in China, you get the very opposite. it. And so there's this interesting cultural difference where people in the East seem to predict much more change, variation, balance, correction. When a stock's been doing well, the other shoe is about to drop. And so the stock's probably going to decline. When it's been doing badly, it's likely to do
或者我会给他们看一些天气图表，我会说，嘿，已经连续10天晴天了。你认为明天会发生什么？他们会预测更多的阳光。或者如果一直在下雨，他们预测会下更多的雨。但在东方，在韩国、日本、中国，你得到的结果恰恰相反。所以存在这种有趣的文化差异，东方的人似乎预测更多的变化、波动、平衡和修正。当一只股票表现良好时，另一只靴子即将掉下来。所以股票可能会下跌。当它表现糟糕时，它很可能会
well. It's been sunny. It's going to start raining and so on. And one of the interesting things about the view that the West seems to have of change, which is that it's unusual, is that it leaves you uniquely ill-prepared for the fact that life is not linear. that actually there are a lot of changes that happen constantly, and we seem to be blindsided by that when we anticipate that there aren't going to be any changes. But from the point of view of being stuck, you can now see a situation where, in fact,
表现良好。天晴了。要开始下雨了，以此类推。关于西方似乎对变化的看法——即变化是不寻常的——一个有趣的事情是，它让你在面对生活不是线性的这一事实时显得格外准备不足。实际上，有很多变化不断发生，而当我们预期不会有任何变化时，我们似乎会被这些变化打个措手不及。但从被卡住的角度来看，你现在可以看到一种情况，事实上，
you're going through a period of an extended slump, for example, and it's easy to feel, you know, I'm never going to get out of the slump, because again, I feel like if it's been raining nine days in a row, it's going to be raining the 10th day as well. And, of course, that then contributes to my feeling of, I will never get out of this rut that I'm in. Yeah, and so it's a sort of double-edged trap there where you are blindsided when things go badly and when you experience stuckness, but also in the midst of that stuckness, you can't imagine it ever-ending. You write about a video posted online by the actress Brie Larson. She won an Academy Award for Best Actress for her role in the movie Room, and she's had leading roles in blockbuster movies like The Marvels.
例如，当你经历一段漫长的低谷期时，很容易会觉得“我永远也走不出这个低谷了”，因为我总觉得如果已经连续下了九天雨，第十天也一定会下雨。当然，这会加重我的那种感觉，即我永远无法摆脱目前的困境。是的，这是一种双重陷阱：当你事情进展不顺或感到受阻时，你会感到措手不及，而且在受阻的过程中，你无法想象这种状态会有结束的一天。你写到了女演员布丽·拉尔森在网上发布的一段视频。她凭借电影《房间》获得了奥斯卡最佳女主角奖，并在《惊奇队长》等大片中担任主角。
In this clip, she talks about the secret of her success. I got told no 98 to 99% of the time. I know it's hard to like fully wrap your brain around. It's even hard for me to wrap my brain around to think of the fact that I've been on like thousands and thousands and thousands and thousands of auditions is sort of crazy.
在这段视频中，她谈到了自己成功的秘诀。她说：“我98%到99%的时间都被拒绝。我知道这很难让人完全理解。甚至连我自己都很难想象，我参加过成千上万次试镜，这简直太疯狂了。”
So that's a lot of failure, Adam, and not what you think of when you think about a very successful movie star. So often we focus on colossal success. But for someone with Brilarsen's degree of success to be transparent about her failures and the fact that by her own account, it's 98 to 99% of the time that she's failing, I think is really disarming and offers a real note of hope. And so not surprisingly, people really latched onto that video. And I found it a very interesting piece of evidence. I'm wondering if there's an important insight here, which is that succeeding often means a sustained tolerance for failure. I mean, it sounds paradoxical, but winners are not people who never lose. they're people who can tolerate losing long enough for things to break their way.
所以，亚当，那意味着大量的失败，这和你心目中非常成功的电影明星形象完全不同。我们往往只关注巨大的成功。但对于像布丽·拉尔森这样成功的人来说，能够坦诚面对自己的失败，并且承认自己98%到99%的时间都在经历失败，我认为这非常令人释怀，也提供了一种真正的希望。不出所料，人们非常关注那段视频。我发现这是一个非常有趣的证据。我想知道这里是否有一个重要的见解，那就是成功往往意味着对失败的持续容忍。我的意思是，这听起来很矛盾，但赢家并不是从不失败的人，而是那些能够忍受失败，直到事情出现转机的人。
Yeah, and there's a lot of research looking, for example, at the course of careers in various different pursuits. They look at artists, they look at film writers, they look at book writers and other people, and ask where is the most successful period of that artist's life's work. And the answer is it's hard to predict. And there are people they describe as having early in their careers, they have their biggest successes, some during the summertime in the middle of their careers, and then some during the fall or the wintertime at the end of their careers. And so, yet, you don't know necessarily where those periods are going to arise, but you have to stay in the game, keep pushing even against maybe 98 to 99% of failure, as Larson describes,
是的，有很多研究考察了各种不同职业生涯的历程。他们研究艺术家、电影编剧、书籍作家和其他人，询问他们人生中最成功的时期是在什么时候。答案是很难预测。有些人职业生涯早期就取得了最大的成功，有些人是在职业生涯中期的“夏季”，还有些人是在职业生涯末期的“秋季”或“冬季”。所以，你并不一定知道这些时期会在何时出现，但你必须坚持下去，即使像拉尔森所描述的那样，面对98%到99%的失败，也要继续努力，
for the successes to emerge. Now, perhaps because our model of success is the model of, you know, I buy a lottery ticket and I hit the jackpot on the first try, that's the model. many of us think we have to achieve success in one fell swoop. So we bet the house on some one thing. And we say this is going to be the golden ticket. But of course, if that one thing fails, we've left ourselves nothing to fall back on. Yeah, I think this sort of binary view of success and failure in our culture is really, really damaging.
这样成功才会出现。现在，也许是因为我们的成功模式是“买一张彩票，第一次就中大奖”，这就是那种模式。我们许多人认为必须一蹴而就地取得成功。所以我们把赌注押在某一件事情上。我们说这就是“金票”。但当然，如果那件事失败了，我们就没有退路了。是的，我认为我们文化中这种对成功和失败的二元看法是非常、非常有害的。
Because success, really, by that very narrow definition, happens very, very seldom. And so there needs to be a stark reframing. I think one of the best places to begin is to start. thinking about success as this kind of binary instant outcome and to think of it more as a process or a journey or a system that you employ day after day. So instead of saying success is writing 100,000 words of a book, success needs to be something like waking up and writing 300 words today or sitting for an hour in writing and seeing what comes out of that because then at least you make it a narrower definition that means success happens much more often. And you also move the
因为按照那种狭隘的定义，成功确实很少发生。因此，需要进行彻底的重新定义。我认为最好的开始方式是，不要把成功看作是一种二元的即时结果，而要把它看作是一个过程、一段旅程或你日复一日采用的系统。所以，不要说成功就是写完一本书的十万字，成功应该是像今天醒来写下三百字，或者坐下来写一个小时，看看能写出什么。因为这样至少你缩小了定义，意味着成功发生的频率会高得多。而且你也将
domain of success into something you can control, right? than something that's outside of your control. Exactly, yeah. You bring the locus of control inside, which is really valuable, right? Because it's empowering as opposed to forcing you to throw your hands up and say, I don't know what I can do about this. You know, I'm at the mercy of all sorts of external constraints that I don't have much rollover.
成功的领域转移到了你可以控制的事情上，对吧？而不是那些你无法控制的事情。完全正确。你把控制点转移到了内部，这非常有价值，对吧？因为它赋予了你力量，而不是强迫你摊开双手说：“我对此无能为力。”你知道，我受制于各种我无法掌控的外部约束。
And I think that's really, really hopeful and helps people move forward. You know, I remember talking some years ago with another Adam. This is Adam Grant at the University of Pennsylvania. And he told me there was a strong correlation between artists who were successful and artists who are prolific. You've looked at the same idea as well. Can you talk about how, in some ways, taking more shots on goal
我认为这真的非常给人希望，并帮助人们继续前进。你知道，我记得几年前和另一位亚当交谈过。那是宾夕法尼亚大学的亚当·格兰特。他告诉我，成功的艺术家和多产的艺术家之间存在很强的相关性。你也研究过同样的观点。你能谈谈在某种程度上，多尝试几次射门
makes it more likely to also take really good shots on goal? Yeah, that's exactly right, that quality and quantity are related strongly, that the more times you try, the more likely you are to hit on a success. And there are lots of reasons for that. One is that, obviously, by trying more, you learn what works and what doesn't,
是否也更有可能射出高质量的球吗？是的，完全正确，质量和数量有着密切的联系，你尝试的次数越多，就越有可能获得成功。这有很多原因。其中之一显然是，通过更多的尝试，你会学到什么有效，什么无效，
and so what you produce ultimately gets stronger over time. But also, sometimes it's hard to know what will succeed. And so let's say there are 10 different ways to do something. If you try three of them, you have a three in 10 chance of hitting whatever the jackpot is. If you try all 10, one of them is going to succeed. And so you need to have those misses in order to ultimately have the success in aggregate. And so that's a really important principle in any pursuit. It doesn't really matter what you're doing.
所以你最终产出的东西会随着时间的推移而变得更强。但同时，有时很难知道什么会成功。假设有10种不同的方法来做某事。如果你尝试了其中3种，你就有十分之三的机会中大奖。如果你尝试了全部10种，其中一种肯定会成功。所以你需要有那些失败，才能最终获得总体的成功。这在任何追求中都是一个非常重要的原则。你正在做什么其实并不重要。
But trying multiple approaches, experimenting, figuring out whether the dominant approach, which is the right one or whether you should try something a bit different is the way forward. We've looked at several ways that our own minds can become our worst enemies and cause us to become stuck. Of course, sometimes the problem is not inside our own minds. We're just dealing with a problem that is really difficult. But it turns out, here too, there are things we can do and things we shouldn't do to get unstuck. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. Adam Alter is a psychologist at NYU who studies how we get stuck and how to get unstuck.
但是尝试多种方法、进行实验、弄清楚主流方法是否是正确的方法，或者你是否应该尝试一些不同的方法，才是前进的方向。我们已经研究了我们自己的思想如何成为我们最大的敌人并导致我们陷入困境的几种方式。当然，有时问题并不在于我们自己的思想。我们只是在处理一个非常困难的问题。但事实证明，在这里，我们也可以做一些事情，或者避免做一些事情来摆脱困境。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。亚当·奥尔特是纽约大学的一位心理学家，他研究我们是如何陷入困境以及如何摆脱困境的。
He has examined a number of mental traps we construct that can make it hard for us to extricate ourselves. But sometimes the challenge is not inside our own minds. The problems we face are inherently challenging. But here again, it turns out that our minds can play an important role in finding our way to break-throughs. Adam, in a survey that you conducted, you asked people about their experience. experiences getting stuck. And one of your respondents talked about trying to learn to play the piano and another talked about trying to become a good artist. Can you tell me what they told you? Yeah. So they both explained that they had made some steady progress earlier on in the experience
他研究了我们构建的许多心理陷阱，这些陷阱可能使我们难以自拔。但有时挑战并不在于我们自己的思想。我们面临的问题本身就具有挑战性。但在这里，事实证明我们的思想在寻找突破口方面也能发挥重要作用。亚当，在你进行的一项调查中，你询问了人们关于他们陷入困境的经历。你的一位受访者谈到了尝试学习弹钢琴，另一位谈到了尝试成为一名优秀的艺术家。你能告诉我他们告诉了你什么吗？是的。他们都解释说，他们在经历的早期取得了一些稳定的进展，
but ultimately hit what they described as a plateau, that they couldn't improve further. They reached a particular point and then did not seem to continue to improve beyond that point. So here's the one about the piano. I've been trying to learn how to play the piano. I was making steady progress, but in the last couple of years, I feel I haven't improved at all. I continue to practice the basics, but I feel stuck, and it's making me worry that I'll never improve.
但最终遇到了他们所描述的“平台期”，即他们无法再进一步提高。他们达到了某一点，然后似乎无法继续超越该点。这是关于钢琴的那一个：“我一直在尝试学习如何弹钢琴。我取得了稳定的进展，但在过去几年里，我觉得我一点也没有进步。我继续练习基础知识，但我感到受阻，这让我担心我永远不会进步。”
It feels as if I'm wasting my time. And then this one's from an artist. I've hit a plateau and can't seem to improve further. I need to practice to put my nose to the grindstone to improve my skill in drawing portraits and landscapes. I need to learn how to be more creative and to find creative solutions to my problems. If you have an exercise program
感觉就像我在浪费时间。然后这是来自一位艺术家的：“我遇到了瓶颈，似乎无法再进一步提高。我需要练习，需要刻苦钻研，以提高我绘制肖像和风景的技能。我需要学习如何更有创造力，并找到解决问题的创造性方案。如果你有一个锻炼计划，
and have been doing it for a while, you have very likely encountered the plateau effect. Studies of athletes in nearly every sport show this too. Adam cites one study. This is research that looks at roughly 15,000 people over about seven years and looks at a very simple training regime that they took part in
并且已经坚持了一段时间，你很可能遇到过“平台效应”。几乎所有运动项目的运动员研究也显示了这一点。亚当引用了一项研究。这项研究观察了大约七年间约15,000人，并观察了他们参与的一项非常简单的训练方案，
and wanted to understand the effectiveness of this regime across time. And what the researchers found was that for the first year and sometimes two years in some of the respondents who were particularly responsive, people became fitter, they became healthier, they became happier in certain respects. But beyond that two-year process, there weren't great benefits to using exactly the same approach in the remaining three, four, five, six, seven years. And so by doing the same thing over and over and over again, responsiveness declines, whether it's physical responsiveness to a training regime or whether it's
并试图了解该方案随时间的有效性。研究人员发现，在第一年，有时在一些反应特别灵敏的受访者中是两年，人们变得更健康、更强壮，在某些方面也更快乐。但超过那两年的过程后，在剩下的三、四、五、六、七年里，使用完全相同的方法并没有带来太大的好处。所以通过一遍又一遍地做同样的事情，反应能力会下降，无论是对训练方案的身体反应，还是
the approach you've been using to learn the piano or to draw or paint. And what explains this plateau effect, Adam? One for the bodies in particular is that you become habituated. And so your muscles perhaps adapt to what you're doing and they stop responding in the same way as they did earlier on. They effectively become experts at coping with what you're throwing at them. And the problem with expertise with respect to muscles is they stop needing to try quite so hard to do what it is you're asking of them. And so as a result, because you're not stretching them further, they don't continue to improve. And that's true of cardio fitness as well and various other forms of fitness. So by changing
你用来学习钢琴、绘画或涂鸦的方法。亚当，是什么解释了这种平台效应？对于身体而言，特别是你变得习惯了。所以你的肌肉可能适应了你正在做的事情，它们不再像早期那样做出同样的反应。它们实际上成为了应对你所施加压力的专家。而关于肌肉的专业知识的问题在于，它们不再需要像你要求它们做的那样努力工作。因此，因为你没有进一步拉伸它们，它们就不会继续改善。心肺功能和其他各种形式的健身也是如此。所以通过改变
things, you then reintroduce some stress into the situation and that leads to greater improvement. And really, it's a similar idea with the piano or with art or with any other domain that you can do the same thing over and over again, and you might become more comfortable with it over time, but eventually that comfort just has no real value to you. You need to change things, and part of that is just making things a little bit more difficult, whether it's trying a new technique or stretching yourself in some other way. Without doing that, you're basically going to hit this point of stagnation. I want to talk about another kind of challenge we sometimes encounter. Sometimes the problems we're confronting are so complex that we find ourselves bewildered by the number of options before us.
事物，你就会重新引入一些压力，这会导致更大的改善。实际上，钢琴、艺术或任何其他领域也是类似的想法，你可以一遍又一遍地做同样的事情，随着时间的推移，你可能会对它感到更舒适，但最终这种舒适对你来说没有任何真正的价值。你需要改变事物，其中一部分就是让事情变得稍微困难一点，无论是尝试一种新技术还是以其他方式拉伸自己。如果不这样做，你基本上会达到这种停滞点。我想谈谈我们有时遇到的另一种挑战。有时我们面临的问题太复杂了，以至于我们被面前众多的选择弄得不知所措。
And now throwing lots of spaghetti at the wall, you know, produces a mess rather than an insight. Can you talk about this idea that sometimes reducing our own options can be a worthwhile strategy? Yeah, I studied law as an undergraduate, and one of the things they taught us very early on was you will always have too much information. You know, you'll get facts about a particular case. Most of them will be extraneous. They're not really relevant to the kernel of the case that's really important to understand. And your biggest job is to find what really matters, to simplify. And I think that's an incredibly valuable skill to use in any situation because so many things that we grapple with every day are complex by nature. You know, it really doesn't matter what kind of
现在，把很多意大利面扔到墙上，只会产生一团糟，而不是洞察力。你能谈谈这种观点吗，即有时减少我们自己的选择可能是一种有价值的策略？是的，我本科学习法律时，他们很早就教给我们的一件事是：你总是会拥有过多的信息。你知道，你会得到关于某个案件的事实。其中大部分是无关紧要的。它们与理解案件核心真正重要的部分并不相关。而你最大的工作是找到真正重要的东西，进行简化。我认为这在任何情况下都是一种非常有价值的技能，因为我们每天处理的许多事情本质上都是复杂的。你知道，无论你从事什么样的工作，
work you do. If you're a doctor, the process of diagnosis is going to be complicated. If you're a lawyer, it'll be complicated. If you're trying to understand the financial markets, there'll be too much information. And so I think the difference between being a great success and perhaps a more modest success is in learning how to instinctively figure out what really matters, stripping away what's not absolutely necessary, and really imposing artificial constraints that make what might otherwise be overwhelmingly complex much simpler. You write about the French artist Pierre Soulej, who has used a really unusual self-imposed restraint on himself in order to grant himself more freedom. What does he do?
这真的不重要。如果你是一名医生，诊断过程会很复杂。如果你是一名律师，它会很复杂。如果你试图了解金融市场，信息会太多。所以我认为，成为一个巨大的成功者和一个更温和的成功者之间的区别在于，学习如何本能地找出真正重要的东西，剥离掉那些并非绝对必要的东西，并真正施加人为的限制，使那些原本可能极其复杂的事情变得简单得多。你写到了法国艺术家皮埃尔·苏拉热，他对自己施加了一种非常不寻常的自我约束，以便给自己更多的自由。他做了什么？
Yeah. So, Solange talked about the fact that the business of art was complex, very complex. You have just so many materials at your disposal. You have different media. And then, of course, once you narrow down the medium, you then still have to decide on color. And so what Solage decided quite early on was that he was just. going to use black paint. And by stripping away the question of color, of hue, he would leave himself with a much simpler set of decisions to make. And so he could really focus and refine his
是的。所以，苏拉热谈到了艺术行业很复杂，非常复杂。你手头有太多的材料。你有不同的媒介。然后，当然，一旦你缩小了媒介范围，你仍然必须决定颜色。所以苏拉热很早就决定，他只是要使用黑色颜料。通过剥离颜色和色调的问题，他会给自己留下更简单的一系列决定。所以他可以真正专注于并完善他
understanding of how to use that one tone of paint to create the works that he was making. And so he became known as the artist who only used black paint. When you feel stuck because you have hit a dreaded plateau, the solution is to introduce change. Start a new kind of workout. If you are a writer of prose, try your hand at poetry. If you're a musician, try playing your instrument with your non-dominant hand. Adam has also studied the idea that reframing problems as challenges can be effective in getting yourself unstuck. He has looked at one particular kind of problem that many people confront in workplaces and educational settings. There's a very well-known phenomenon in social psychology known as stereotype threat, which is the idea that
对如何使用那种单一色调的颜料来创作他正在制作的作品的理解。因此，他被称为只使用黑色颜料的艺术家。当你因为遇到了可怕的平台期而感到受阻时，解决方案是引入变化。开始一种新的锻炼方式。如果你是散文作家，尝试一下诗歌。如果你是音乐家，尝试用非惯用手演奏你的乐器。亚当还研究了将问题重新定义为挑战可以有效地让你摆脱困境的观点。他研究了许多人在工作场所和教育环境中面临的一种特定问题。社会心理学中有一个非常著名的现象，称为“刻板印象威胁”，即如果你知道
if you know that you belong to a particular group that is negatively stereotyped in a particular domain, just knowing that is overwhelming and it makes it harder for you to perform well. So some of the research looked at women in mathematics, a domain that was at least historically in a sexist norm seen as the domain of men. And so when women are reminded that they are women and they are trying to complete math tasks, there's some evidence that it becomes harder for them because they recognize that in addition to the baggage of having to overcome the challenges of the task, they also have to deal with the fact that they are part of a group that is negatively stereotyped in that domain. So that's this idea of stereotype
你属于某个在特定领域被负面刻板印象化的群体，仅仅知道这一点就是压倒性的，它会让你更难表现出色。因此，一些研究考察了数学领域的女性，这个领域至少在历史上，在性别歧视的规范中被视为男性的领域。因此，当女性被提醒她们是女性并且正在尝试完成数学任务时，有一些证据表明这变得更难了，因为她们意识到，除了必须克服任务挑战的负担之外，她们还必须处理这样一个事实：她们是该领域中被负面刻板印象化的群体的一部分。所以这就是“刻板印象威胁”的概念，
threat, but a lot of what's experienced in a threat is subjective. It's the way you perceive the situation. And so this research I did looked at trying to take people at Princeton who were like I was from an underrepresented background in the sense that we weren't from feeder schools that tended to send lots of students to Princeton, and to ask them to complete a math task, and to have some of them think about that as a threatening situation, as a sort of test of their intellectual ability, and for others to just recognize that this was just a challenge,
但威胁中经历的很多东西是主观的。这是你感知情况的方式。所以我做的这项研究试图选取普林斯顿大学的人，他们像我一样来自代表性不足的背景，因为我们不是来自倾向于向普林斯顿输送大量学生的预科学校，并要求他们完成一项数学任务，让其中一些人把这看作是一种威胁性的情况，作为一种对其智力能力的测试，而让其他人只是认识到这仅仅是一个挑战，
it was something fun that they were doing, and to turn the dial down on that experience of threat and to show that even if you're from that underrepresented background in that context, you are still able to overcome that particular task if you see it as a challenge rather than as a threat. So it seems, Adam, that there are times when we know what we want, but we're stuck because we don't know how to get there. But at other times, we're stuck because we simply don't know what we want. I want to play you a clip from a film that captures this feeling.
这是一种他们正在做的有趣的事情，通过降低对威胁的感知，并展示即使你来自那个背景下代表性不足的群体，只要你将其视为挑战而非威胁，你仍然能够克服那个特定的任务。所以，亚当，似乎有时候我们知道自己想要什么，但却因为不知道如何实现而陷入困境。但另一些时候，我们陷入困境是因为我们根本不知道自己想要什么。我想给你播放一段电影片段，它捕捉到了这种感觉。
In the 2003 movie Lost in Translation, Scala Johansson plays Charlotte, a young woman who feels a drift in her life. And she meets up with an over-the-hale movie star played by Bill Murray, and she asks him for guidance. I'm stuck. I just don't know what I'm supposed to be. You know? I tried being a writer, but I hate what I write. And I tried taking pictures. But they're so mediocre, you know,
在2003年的电影《迷失东京》中，斯嘉丽·约翰逊饰演夏洛特，一个在生活中感到迷茫的年轻女性。她遇到了比尔·默瑞饰演的一位过气的电影明星，并向他寻求指导。她说：我陷入了困境。我不知道自己应该成为什么样的人。你知道吗？我尝试过写作，但我讨厌我写的东西。我也尝试过摄影，但它们太平庸了，你知道，
and every girl goes through a photography phase. So a motto that recurs in your book, Adam, is action above all. What does that mean? Yeah, it means that a lot of the book is about the emotional experience of being stuck and then about the mental strategies we can use to move forward. But all of that ultimately is in the service of action. Being stuck is about being physically in a particular place or mentally in a particular place and wanting to be somewhere else.
每个女孩都会经历一个摄影阶段。所以，亚当，你书中反复出现的一个座右铭是“行动至上”。这是什么意思？是的，这意味着书中的大部分内容是关于陷入困境的情感体验，以及我们可以用来前进的心理策略。但所有这些最终都是为了行动服务。陷入困境是指在身体上或心理上处于某个特定的位置，却想要去别的地方。
The only way you can change that is not changing how you emotionally appraise the situation, not with mental strategies, but ultimately the thing you have to do more than anything else is to act, is to move in a particular direction. Well, why would action help us when we don't know where we want to go? By acting, you reveal something to yourself. If I don't know if I want to be a painter, if I want to be a writer, if I want to be a doctor, if I want to be a lawyer, I can sit here and ponder that question. To a certain point, there's value in that, but eventually thinking about it harder and more
你改变这一点的唯一方法不是改变你对情况的情感评估，也不是靠心理策略，最终你必须做的事情比任何其他事情都重要，那就是行动，即朝着特定的方向前进。那么，当我们不知道自己想去哪里时，行动为什么会有帮助呢？通过行动，你会向自己揭示一些东西。如果我不知道自己是想成为画家、作家、医生还是律师，我可以坐在这里思考这个问题。在某种程度上，这有其价值，但最终，更深入地思考并不能让我走得太远。
deeply just doesn't get me very far. What will get me somewhere is to inhabit the life of an artist or a painter or or a doctor or a lawyer, to take action, to do something that's a bit different. And even if I'm moving in the wrong direction, even if art turns out not to be my calling, the law is not my calling, and so on, I learn something about what either does work in the best case scenario or in the worst case scenario, I'm eliminating what doesn't. And that's tremendously valuable, certainly much more valuable than sitting still and just thinking, navel-gazing as it ultimately becomes. You write about an interesting exercise involving the New York Times Spelling Bee.
真正能让我有所进展的是去体验艺术家的生活，或者画家、医生或律师的生活，去采取行动，去做一些稍微不同的事情。即使我走错了方向，即使艺术证明不是我的使命，法律也不是我的使命，等等，我也能学到一些关于什么在最佳情况下有效，或者在最坏的情况下，我排除了什么无效。这非常有价值，肯定比坐着不动、陷入自我沉思要更有价值。你写了一个关于《纽约时报》拼字游戏的有趣练习。
Tell me what that puzzle involves and the hack to basically try and do better at it. You get a series of letters before you and you have to make words out of those letters. And the letters when you first open the app are in a particular configuration. There's a central letter and then there are some letters, six letters surrounding that central letter. But there's a button that allows you to shuffle the order of those letters. letters to randomly reallocate them. And what's really fascinating is I didn't intuit this when I first started doing the puzzle, but what I'll do today is I'll sit with the letters as they arrive when I open the app and I'll try to find words for, say, 10 minutes and I'll get to a certain level
告诉我那个谜题涉及什么，以及试图做得更好的技巧。你面前有一系列字母，你必须用这些字母组成单词。当你第一次打开应用程序时，字母处于特定的配置中。有一个中心字母，周围有六个字母。但有一个按钮可以让你随机重新分配这些字母的顺序。非常迷人的是，我刚开始玩这个游戏时并没有直觉到这一点，但我今天会做的是，当我打开应用程序时，我会看着出现的字母，尝试寻找单词，比如10分钟，我会达到某个水平，
and usually it's not as far as I'll want to go. There are different levels of achievement. I always try to go for the top level. And if I fall a little bit short of that, I'll hit the shuffle button. It'll reorient the letters. It'll change the order. of them. And what's fascinating is I've been staring at these letters. It shouldn't matter where they are, but by moving them into a new position, suddenly a whole raft of new words appear and are available to me. And it's, if it can work in this very impoverished context where all you're looking at is exactly the same set of seven letters just in slightly different places, if it works there and unsticks you there, if you can adopt a pretty serious, profound change of perspective
通常这还达不到我想要的程度。成就水平有高低之分。我总是尝试达到最高水平。如果我离那个目标还差一点，我会按下随机按钮。它会重新排列字母。它会改变它们的顺序。令人着迷的是，我一直盯着这些字母看。它们在哪里本不应该有关系，但通过将它们移动到新的位置，突然间一大批新单词出现了，并且可以供我使用。如果这在这样一个非常贫乏的环境中有效，即你所看到的只是完全相同的一组七个字母，只是位置略有不同，如果它在那里有效并让你摆脱困境，如果你能采取一种非常严肃、深刻的视角转变，
in other areas of life, the payback is pretty dramatic. There's a great return on that investment. I want to talk about a challenge that you confronted in your own life, and I think this might be a useful example of a problem that might be basically unsolvable. You were in your late 20s and you felt torn between remaining in the United States where you had great academic and career opportunities and returning home to Australia and to your family. Describe those two forces at him and what it felt like to be pulled in different directions. Yeah, this was an interesting moment. I'd been in the United States for five years in grad school, and if all went well, I would have a PhD, and then I would do something next. I wasn't sure
在生活的其他领域，回报是非常显著的。那项投资有巨大的回报。我想谈谈你在自己生活中遇到的一个挑战，我认为这可能是一个基本上无法解决的问题的有用例子。你在20多岁时，感到在留在拥有巨大学术和职业机会的美国，还是回到澳大利亚的家乡和家人身边之间左右为难。描述一下这两种力量，亚当，以及被拉向不同方向的感觉。是的，这是一个有趣的时刻。我在美国读了五年研究生，如果一切顺利，我会有博士学位，然后我会做接下来的事情。我不确定
exactly what that next would be. One option was to return back to Australia, to return to the country that I'd come from before. I'm very close to my family, and I felt that it was difficult to be away from them for five years. Another option was to keep moving forward in my career in the United States, and so I did that. But the experience of moving from grad school into the role of an assistant professor at NYU, I found it overwhelming all over again. I felt a little bit stuck. I wasn't sure exactly what direction to poor my resources. I felt a little bit unmoored. And at the time, I was 29 and I'm thinking a lot about what it was like to be at the end of my 20s and moving into my 30s. And I decided that I needed some business.
接下来具体会是什么。一个选择是回到澳大利亚，回到我之前来的国家。我和家人非常亲近，我觉得离开他们五年很困难。另一个选择是继续在美国发展我的职业生涯，所以我这样做了。但是，从研究生转变为纽约大学助理教授的经历，我发现这再次让我感到不知所措。我感到有点陷入困境。我不确定具体应该把资源投入到哪个方向。我感到有点迷失方向。当时我29岁，我一直在思考20多岁末期并迈向30岁是什么感觉。我决定我需要一些事业。
big goal to act as a kind of orienting point. And so I decided that I was going to run a marathon and to spend four months training with a team and to run the New York City Marathon. And there was something profoundly unsticking about that activity of taking on that new goal that it gave me somewhere to pour my anxieties. And it really felt like a great unsticking moment. And I think liberated me to move forward in my life that I just started in New York City. Why do you think running a marathon helps sort of figure out where you should live your life? I mean, the two things seem completely unrelated to each other. Yeah, they do.
一个大目标作为一种定位点。所以我决定去跑马拉松，花四个月时间与一个团队一起训练，并参加纽约马拉松。采取那个新目标的活动有一种深刻的摆脱困境的作用，它给了我一个倾注焦虑的地方。这真的感觉是一个伟大的摆脱困境的时刻。我认为这解放了我，让我能够继续我刚在纽约市开始的生活。你为什么认为跑马拉松有助于弄清楚你应该在哪里生活？我的意思是，这两件事看起来完全无关。是的，确实如此。
So one of the things that happens, this is why I mentioned that I was in my late 20s, just imagining being 30, is that that's one of the moments in life. I have some research on this with a colleague of mine, Hal Herschfield, showing that when our ages end in a 9, 29, 39, 49, and so on, it's a moment when we zoom back and think about the meaningfulness of our life. We think about whether we're making the right life decisions. We sort of see the passage of time much more vividly than we do at age, say, 24, 25, 34, 35 in the middle of those decades. And at that moment, just having a goal imbued my life with meaning and sort of made me feel that I could move forward again. Even if it was an unrelated goal, the mere fact of having that goal gave me that sense of momentum that I felt was important at that time in my life. I mean, I think what I'm partly hearing is that when we are feeling stuck, feeling like we have movement in some domain of our lives,
所以发生的一件事是，这就是为什么我提到我20多岁末期，想象自己30岁，这是人生中的时刻之一。我和我的同事哈尔·赫什菲尔德对此有一些研究，表明当我们的年龄以9结尾时，比如29、39、49等等，这是一个我们回顾并思考生活意义的时刻。我们思考我们是否做出了正确的人生决定。我们看到的时光流逝比我们在24、25、34、35岁等十年中间时要生动得多。在那一刻，仅仅拥有一个目标就赋予了我的生活意义，并让我觉得我可以再次前进。即使这是一个不相关的目标，仅仅拥有那个目标的事实也给了我那种我在人生那个阶段认为很重要的动力感。我的意思是，我想我听到的一部分是，当我们感到陷入困境时，感到我们在生活的某个领域有进展，
even if it isn't the primary domain in which we are feeling stuck, can be helpful in unsticking us. Exactly. Yeah, I think the sense of movement, the sense of velocity is more important than what the velocity specifically and narrowly, concretely represents. It's just the feeling that you are not stagnant. Adam Alter is a psychologist at New York University. He is the author of the book, anatomy of a breakthrough, how to get unstuck when it matters most.
即使它不是我们感到陷入困境的主要领域，也可能有助于我们摆脱困境。正是如此。是的，我认为运动感、速度感比速度具体、狭隘、具体代表什么更重要。这只是你没有停滞不前的感觉。亚当·奥尔特是纽约大学的心理学家。他是《突破的解剖：如何在最重要的时候摆脱困境》一书的作者。
Adam, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me, Shankar. After the break, your questions answered. Researcher George Bonanno responds to listener questions and comments about his work on trauma. We'll discuss his surprising and hopeful findings about how we cope with the worst that life can throw at us. You won't want to miss it. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
亚当，非常感谢你今天参加“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢你的邀请，尚卡尔。休息之后，回答你们的问题。研究员乔治·博南诺将回应听众关于他创伤研究的问题和评论。我们将讨论他关于我们如何应对生活中最糟糕的事情的令人惊讶且充满希望的发现。你不会想错过的。你正在收听“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. To be human is to be vulnerable to suffering. Poets and philosophers have told us for centuries that the twin side of happiness is grief. The flip side of success is catastrophe. A life filled with contentment is also going to have moments of despair. When we lose a loved one, or experience a serious injury, or confront a natural disaster,
这是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。作为人类，就容易受到痛苦的伤害。几个世纪以来，诗人和哲学家告诉我们，幸福的另一面是悲伤。成功的另一面是灾难。充满满足感的生活也会有绝望的时刻。当我们失去亲人，或遭受严重伤害，或面对自然灾害时，
many of us imagine that we will go through, through a predictable emotional journey. Social media influencers, drawing from earlier psychological theories, tell us to expect various stages of grief in a fixed pattern. The idea that people respond in a uniform way to challenges and suffering is simply not true, says Columbia University Clinical Psychologist George Bonanno. In reality, people respond very differently to difficult times and circumstances. George was my guest on two previous episodes,
我们许多人想象我们会经历一段可预测的情感旅程。社交媒体影响者借鉴早期的心理学理论，告诉我们要期待悲伤的各个阶段以固定的模式出现。哥伦比亚大学临床心理学家乔治·博南诺说，人们以统一的方式应对挑战和痛苦的想法根本不是真的。实际上，人们对困难时期和环境的反应非常不同。乔治是我之前两集的嘉宾，
titled The Trauma Script and How to Be More Resilient. Today, in our popular listener segment, Your Questions Answered, we've invited George back to answer your questions about trauma and resilience. George Bonano, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. Nice to talk with you again. George, I want to start with a note from a listener named Janet. Like a number of others, she experienced a major and abrupt loss. her father died by suicide when she was five.
标题分别是《创伤剧本》和《如何变得更具韧性》。今天，在我们受欢迎的听众环节“回答你的问题”中，我们邀请乔治回来回答你们关于创伤和韧性的问题。乔治·博南诺，欢迎回到“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴再次与你交谈。乔治，我想从一位名叫珍妮特的听众的来信开始。像许多其他人一样，她经历了一次重大而突然的损失。她五岁时，父亲自杀身亡。
He had been hospitalized for at least a year and had mental illness. He had already been away from the home for so long that it didn't really change my day-to-day experience. And I don't tend to cry a lot. So my mother worried that I was not grieving enough. And that made me feel bad and guilty, kind of. Like, yeah, why aren't I more upset? And then when I was 10, my oldest brother, who was 20, was killed in a car accident. But again, his absence didn't affect my day-to-day experience.
他至少住院了一年，患有精神疾病。他离开家已经太久了，以至于并没有真正改变我的日常体验。而且我不太容易哭。所以我母亲担心我悲伤得不够。这让我感到难过和内疚，有点像，是的，为什么我不更难过呢？然后当我10岁时，我20岁的大哥在车祸中丧生。但同样，他的缺席并没有影响我的日常体验。
And again, my mother was upset with me for not being more upset. So George, Janet felt like she was being made out to be cold and unfeeling. When we talked last, you told me about your own reaction to your father's death. You didn't break down and you were surprised because tears fail to come. Talk about the expectations we have about grief and the expectations that others have about how we ought to grieve. Yeah, Janet's example is a really nice example of this. These are painful losses, obviously.
而且我母亲再次因为我没有表现得更难过而对我感到不满。所以乔治，珍妮特觉得她被塑造成了一个冷漠无情的人。上次我们交谈时，你告诉我你对自己父亲去世的反应。你没有崩溃，你很惊讶，因为眼泪没有流出来。谈谈我们对悲伤的期望，以及其他人对我们应该如何悲伤的期望。是的，珍妮特的例子是一个非常好的例子。这些显然是痛苦的损失，
but what we've learned is that everybody grieves in their own way. The task of grieving is to recalibrate our minds to a world where the person is no longer alive. However we do that is our own business in a sense. There is no prescription on the best way to do that. We have some natural responses, sadness, moments of reflection in which we do that. but whether or not somebody's outwardly showing grief or crying or not crying or behaving differently or the same, none of those things really matter as long as that task is accomplished,
但我们学到的是，每个人都以自己的方式悲伤。悲伤的任务是调整我们的思想，以适应一个人不再活着的世界。从某种意义上说，我们如何做到这一点是我们自己的事。关于最好的做法没有处方。我们有一些自然的反应，悲伤，反思的时刻，我们在其中做到这一点。但是，无论某人是否在表面上表现出悲伤或哭泣，或者不哭泣，或者表现得不同或相同，只要任务完成了，这些事情都不重要，
as long as their brains are able to recalibrate. And so, you know, I feel very sympathetic towards Janet for what she went through and also for her feeling bad that she was in a sense castigated for not grieving properly when, in fact, there is no proper way to grieve in that sense. So your research findings contrast with our culture's dominant model of tragedy, the five stages of grief. We talked about this in our earlier conversation as well, George, but talk about why it is that those five stages do not accurately represent
只要他们的大脑能够重新校准。所以，你知道，我非常同情珍妮特所经历的一切，也同情她因为没有适当地悲伤而受到指责，而事实上，在这个意义上没有适当的悲伤方式。所以你的研究结果与我们文化中占主导地位的悲剧模型——悲伤的五个阶段形成了对比。乔治，我们在之前的谈话中也谈到了这一点，但谈谈为什么这五个阶段不能准确地代表
what many people go through when they experience a tragedy or a setback. First of all, as I mentioned when we talked before, that they were originally, Kubler-Ross had proposed those stages, is as a descriptor of how people face their own death. And I have no idea if that's what people do when they face their own death because there isn't much work on that. But they got foisted onto grief onto what people do during bereavement. And they're very prescriptive.
许多人在经历悲剧或挫折时所经历的事情。首先，正如我之前谈到时提到的，库伯勒-罗斯最初提出这些阶段，是作为人们如何面对自己死亡的描述。我不知道人们在面对自己死亡时是否会这样做，因为关于这方面的研究不多。但它们被强加到了悲伤上，强加到了人们在丧亲期间所做的事情上。而且它们非常具有规定性。
And I think they became very popular because they're so prescriptive. And it's, you know, grieving is a mysterious thing. It's a painful event. and we would like to have a roadmap. We would like to have a plan, a kind of a prescription of what we're going to go through. So it became popular in that sense. But the research has never supported this idea
我认为它们变得非常流行，因为它们太具有规定性了。而且，你知道，悲伤是一件神秘的事情。这是一个痛苦的事件。我们想要一张路线图。我们想要一个计划，一种我们将要经历的处方。所以它在那个意义上变得流行。但研究从未支持这个想法，
that people go through these experiences. Some people don't go through any of these experiences in any of these five stages. They're just kind of a handy thing that people hold on to. I think they often cause more harm than good. We received a number of messages from Littenden. who said that this model, you know, where you start with denial, followed by anger, and then bargaining, and then acceptance, that this model didn't fit their grief. And one of the
即人们会经历这些体验。有些人根本不会经历这五个阶段中的任何一个。它们只是人们坚持的一种方便的东西。我认为它们往往弊大于利。我们收到了许多来自听众的消息，他们说这个模型，你知道，你从否认开始，接着是愤怒，然后是讨价还价，最后是接受，这个模型并不符合他们的悲伤。其中一条
messages came from listener, Mary. My husband and I lost our 18-and-a-half-year-old son when he was a freshman at UCLA and involved in an accident. It came as very unexpected and was traumatic for us and for our other son, who at the time was a junior in college in Minnesota, and what resonated for me with your conversation with George Bonano was the discussion about the five stages of grief. How that came about does not apply to, you know, losing a child or losing a spouse because those stages, it's just unrealistic to think that it's a linear path. It's a different lens, a different experience, when one loses a child, especially when it's at that time of life where you're just so optimistic and looking to the future ahead for them. And in an instant, you realize that your future will never be what you expected it to be.
消息来自听众玛丽。我和我丈夫失去了我们18岁半的儿子，当时他在加州大学洛杉矶分校读大一，卷入了一场事故。这非常出乎意料，对我们和我们的另一个儿子来说都是创伤，他当时是明尼苏达大学的大三学生，我和乔治·博南诺的谈话中引起我共鸣的是关于悲伤的五个阶段的讨论。它是如何产生的并不适用于失去孩子或失去配偶，因为那些阶段，认为这是一个线性路径是不现实的。当你失去一个孩子时，这是一个不同的视角，不同的体验，特别是在人生的那个阶段，你非常乐观，对他们的未来充满期待。瞬间，你意识到你的未来永远不会是你所期望的样子。
For me, the loss is something that's ongoing because it's the loss of what I thought was going to be. be the case. Talk about Mary's point here, George, that grief isn't always linear. You say that grief sometimes takes the form of an oscillation between sadness and other kinds of emotions. What does this oscillation look like and what purpose does it, sir? Mary's comment is very interesting in this regard. Grief is very different depending on the type of loss. The oscillation that we've observed is really part of the way that people seem to deal with loss. We focus inward on what's essentially we need to reconcile. We need to come to terms with the fact that a person is gone.
对我来说，这种损失是持续的，因为这是对我所认为会发生的事情的损失。乔治，谈谈玛丽的观点，即悲伤并不总是线性的。你说悲伤有时表现为悲伤和其他情绪之间的波动。这种波动是什么样子的，它有什么目的？玛丽的评论在这方面非常有趣。悲伤根据损失的类型而有很大不同。我们观察到的波动似乎确实是人们处理损失方式的一部分。我们向内关注我们本质上需要调和的东西。我们需要接受一个人已经离开的事实。
And then we focus outward again. I want to speak, though, to Mary's comment, though, about how losing a child is different. There's much less research on loss of a child because it's extra painful and a lot of parents who are grieving, they don't want to be in research. But what Mary said that really struck me that it is really kind of a loss of your future, a sense of, you know, we wrap up so many hopes and expectations and plans, images with our children. And to lose all of those really is a very difficult thing to work through, to reconcile. And it does. And it does, take a long time, I think. There's both the grief over the person's death and also the struggle with what it means that our lives are different than we thought. We heard from another listener
然后我们再次将目光转向外部。不过，我想谈谈玛丽关于失去孩子有何不同的评论。关于丧子之痛的研究要少得多，因为这格外痛苦，许多处于悲伤中的父母并不想参与研究。但玛丽所说的话确实触动了我，那确实是一种对未来的丧失，一种感觉，你知道，我们将太多的希望、期望、计划和对孩子的憧憬寄托在他们身上。失去这一切确实是一件非常难以克服、难以调和的事情。我认为，这确实需要很长的时间。既有对逝者的哀悼，也有对“我们的生活与预想不同”这一事实的挣扎。我们听到了另一位听众的来信，
who also talked about the loss of an imagined future. Her name is Emily. Three years ago, I inherited a neuromuscular disorder from my mother. Prior to that, I was a competitive athlete. and I lost my housing because I could no longer use my body to work. And it was jumping from home to home just trying to survive. I finally got housed and I'm so grateful. But I wanted my previous life. And I still want that life back. So Emily isn't warning a friend or a relative,
她也谈到了失去想象中的未来。她的名字叫艾米丽。三年前，我从母亲那里遗传了一种神经肌肉疾病。在此之前，我是一名竞技运动员。我失去了住所，因为我无法再用身体去工作。我只能在不同的住处之间辗转，努力生存。我最终有了住处，我非常感激。但我想要我以前的生活。我仍然想找回那种生活。所以艾米丽并不是在哀悼一位朋友或亲戚，
George, but she still feels that loss of what might have been. She can't help but think about the alternate version of her life where she is healthy. Is there any research on how common this is after a traumatic event and whether these thoughts are helpful or harmful? There isn't, there isn't, but Emily's situation, it resonates in general with the literature on grief. What they share, what the loss of, what Emily is experiencing with the loss of her role is an athlete and the death of a loved one is that they're both the loss of an identity.
乔治，但她仍然感受到了对“可能发生之事”的丧失感。她不禁会去想那个健康的、另一个版本的自己。关于创伤事件后这种情况的普遍性，以及这些想法是有益还是有害，是否有相关研究？并没有，确实没有，但艾米丽的情况与关于悲伤的文献在总体上产生了共鸣。他们共同点在于，艾米丽所经历的失去运动员身份的痛苦，与失去亲人的痛苦，本质上都是一种身份的丧失。
When we lose a person close to us, if they're part of our attachment systems, they're part of who we think of when we think of our lives, we're losing part of our identity. And it's very clear that in Emily's case, I mean, they're very practical things that Emily is lost, but also this sense of who she was. She was an athlete. And that was a big factor in her life. It provider housing, a provider identity, it provided her a role in life doing something that not so many people are able to do. And losing that, I think, is very difficult. I'm glad that Emily was able to get housing. I hope that Emily can find other ways than to find a satisfying life. Many people report these thoughts where they're constantly going back to a what might have been
当我们失去亲近的人时，如果他们是我们依恋系统的一部分，是我们思考生活时会想到的人，那么我们就在失去自我身份的一部分。在艾米丽的案例中，这一点非常明确，我的意思是，艾米丽失去的东西非常实际，但她也失去了对自己身份的认知。她曾是一名运动员。那是她生活中的一个重要因素。它提供了住所，提供了身份，提供了她在生活中做一些并非人人都能做到的事情的角色。我认为失去这些是非常困难的。我很高兴艾米丽能够获得住所。我希望艾米丽能找到除此以外的方式来过上令人满意的生活。许多人报告说，他们会不断地回到“如果当初……”
kind of conversation, where they're asking themselves, what if this hadn't happened to me, what if I hadn't lost someone. I think this is a hallmark of many people who've been through a tragedy imagining this counterfactual universe where things went on as normal. Is this a healthy thing or is this an unhealthy thing, George? I think it's probably healthy to some extent because it's counterfactual thinking is a kind of a reconsideration of the different contingencies in life. But I think ultimately those questions are difficult to answer if we're talking about a loss or a major physical illness, there often is no answer. I experienced this actually myself or had a pretty serious neurological problem in my face that required brain surgery. And it's
这种对话中，他们会问自己，如果这件事没有发生在我身上会怎样，如果我没有失去某人会怎样。我认为这是许多经历过悲剧的人的一个标志，即想象一个事情照常发展的反事实宇宙。乔治，这是一件健康的事情还是一件不健康的事情？我认为在某种程度上这可能是健康的，因为反事实思维是对生活中不同偶然性的一种重新审视。但我认为，如果我们谈论的是丧亲或重大身体疾病，这些问题最终很难回答，因为往往没有答案。其实我自己也经历过，我的面部有严重的神经问题，需要进行脑部手术。而且这
extremely rare, less than a thousandth of a percent, I think, of the people in the U.S. experience this problem. And, you know, the question of why me has no answer. You know, there's just so many random factors in life. So I think at some point this becomes very counterproductive and dangerous. And we know that one of things leading to a worse reaction to loss is rumination. That's when we begin to get into kind of this intractable grief. Sometimes when we're experiencing a painful situation, we can feel like we're all alone. But other times, there are lots of other people around us who are also suffering as well. We received a message from a listener. named Audrey, who says she survived a mass shooting at a house of worship.
极其罕见，我想在美国只有不到十万分之一的人经历过这个问题。而且，你知道，“为什么是我”这个问题没有答案。你知道，生活中有很多随机因素。所以我认为在某种程度上，这会变得非常适得其反且危险。我们知道，导致对丧失反应恶化的因素之一是反刍思维。那就是我们开始陷入那种难以自拔的悲伤的时候。有时当我们经历痛苦的情况时，我们会感到孤立无援。但其他时候，我们周围还有许多人也在遭受同样的痛苦。我们收到了一位名叫奥黛丽的听众的来信，她说她在一家礼拜场所发生的群体枪击事件中幸存了下来。
I've learned a lot about trauma responses in the almost seven years since. As George Bonanno pointed out, not everyone responds in the same way. I found there were what I describe as concentric spheres of effectiveness. Those who were witnesses and survivors occupy a sphere in the center, and working outward those who lost family members, first responders, injured and not, people who might have been there but were not, members of the clergy, members of each of the congregations in the building, the neighborhood, the city, and so on. Within each sphere, the response was quite different among individuals. One thing I observed was that we all began
在过去的近七年里，我学到了很多关于创伤反应的知识。正如乔治·博纳诺所指出的，并非每个人都会以同样的方式做出反应。我发现存在我所描述的“同心圆式的有效性”。那些目击者和幸存者占据了中心圈，向外延伸则是失去家人的亲属、急救人员、受伤者和未受伤者、可能在场但不在场的人、神职人员、大楼内每个会众的成员、邻里、城市等等。在每个圈层内，个人的反应都大不相同。我观察到的一件事是，我们所有人开始
healing more effectively once we started meeting with one another. When an entire group suffers something, healing together seems to be effective, which could explain what Dr. Bonano pointed out about 9-11 survivors in New York. They had to pull together. George, what does the research show about healing from a tragedy when you have people around you who are also going through the tragedy with you? That's a very interesting question. On the one hand, it allows people to share the experience that maybe very few people do experience. It may be very difficult to, for somebody not involved in the event to really understand what a person is struggling with. So in that sense, meeting with the people who were in the event, sharing experiences,
更有效地治愈，是在我们开始相互见面之后。当整个群体遭受某种痛苦时，共同治愈似乎是有效的，这可以解释博纳诺博士提到的纽约9/11幸存者的情况。他们必须团结起来。乔治，研究表明，当你周围的人也和你一起经历悲剧时，从悲剧中的治愈情况如何？这是一个非常有趣的问题。一方面，它让人们能够分享可能很少有人经历过的体验。对于没有参与事件的人来说，要真正理解一个人正在挣扎什么可能非常困难。所以从这个意义上说，与事件中的人见面、分享经历、
supporting each other can be extremely positive. On the other hand, a concern I have, and I'm not in any way suggesting that this happened in Audrey's experience, but this is a concern in general, that we do know also that some of the support groups that tended to evolve around grief and other types of events can sometimes be counterproductive because they keep people kind of constantly re-experiencing the same pain because somebody else would be experiencing the pain even if another person has tended to to move on a little bit. So there's the danger there of kind of group think or group rumination around the topic that I think is real and needs to be, you know, pondered to some.
互相支持可以是非常积极的。另一方面，我有一个担忧，我绝不是在暗示奥黛丽的经历中发生了这种情况，但这通常是一个担忧，我们确实知道，围绕悲伤和其他类型事件演变出来的一些支持小组有时会适得其反，因为它们让人们不断地重温同样的痛苦，因为即使另一个人已经倾向于向前看了一点，其他人可能仍在经历痛苦。所以这里存在一种群体思维或围绕该话题进行群体反刍的危险，我认为这是真实的，需要被，你知道，深思。
extent. But my general take on this is, yes, they could be very helpful, but it could also be harmful in some ways. Hmm. Can you also talk about Audrey's point about the concentric circles of people affected by a tragedy? What do we know about how, you know, frontline workers or journalists or witnesses experience stress and grief? And is it the case that the further you get from the epicenter of the disaster, the less affected that people usually are? Well, that's an interesting question, because that also will very greatly depending on the event. There was some evidence beginning to accrue,
在某种程度上。但我对此的总的看法是，是的，它们可能非常有帮助，但在某些方面也可能是有害的。嗯。你能不能也谈谈奥黛丽关于受悲剧影响的人的同心圆的观点？我们对一线工作人员、记者或目击者如何经历压力和悲伤了解多少？是否确实离灾难中心越远，人们受到的影响通常就越小？嗯，这是一个有趣的问题，因为这也会根据事件的不同而有很大差异。开始有一些证据积累起来，
and it became known as the eye of the hurricane effect, that people right at the very epicenter of a natural disaster sometimes did better than all other people exposed to this event because they got the most resources, because there was the most concern because they were so close to the epicenter. We saw this actually after 9-11 in the schools. The schools that were right downtown near the towers, those kids actually did a lot better than kids out in Queens and Brooklyn in some instances.
这被称为“飓风眼效应”，即处于自然灾害最中心的人有时比所有其他接触到该事件的人表现得更好，因为他们获得了最多的资源，因为人们最关心他们，因为他们离中心太近了。我们实际上在9/11之后的学校里看到了这一点。那些就在市中心靠近双子塔的学校，在某些情况下，那些孩子实际上比皇后区和布鲁克林的孩子表现得好得多。
And those schools where some of those schools are low-resourced schools. They got very little attention and very little help, whereas the kids right downtown got a lot of attention, a lot of resources, a lot of concern, and they did much better. If I may just say one more thing, you also mentioned first responders and journalists. One of the things we've learned is that when there is a disaster, a lot of people are brought into those events with very good intentions, but they may or may not have much training in the kind of psychological challenges
而那些学校中，有些是资源匮乏的学校。他们得到的关注和帮助很少，而市中心的孩子得到了很多关注、很多资源、很多关心，他们表现得好得多。如果我能再说一件事，你也提到了急救人员和记者。我们学到的一件事是，当灾难发生时，很多人怀着非常好的意图被带入这些事件中，但他们可能对他们将要接触到的心理挑战并没有太多训练。
they're going to be exposed to. They may not be prepared to see dead bodies or seriously injured people or a lot of pain and fear. And the research has shown that many of those people who are coming to help will themselves end up being pretty severely traumatized from that kind of event, which is also a consideration in these kinds of, you know, how to respond to these events.
他们可能没有准备好看到尸体或严重受伤的人，或者大量的痛苦和恐惧。研究表明，许多前来帮忙的人自己最终也会因为那种事件而受到相当严重的创伤，这也是在处理这类事件时需要考虑的问题。
So in your research, George, you found three main patterns and how people respond to tragedy. What are these patterns? The three patterns are, first of all, chronic struggle, chronic symptoms. And this is a pattern of people who've gone through the event. They have struggled greatly in the beginning and they simply cannot seem to recover from an event. They continue to struggle over a period of time and eventually they end up struggling in a prolonged way, prolonged suffering. If it's a traumatic event, they're kind of stuck reliving the event
那么在你的研究中，乔治，你发现了人们应对悲剧的三种主要模式。这些模式是什么？这三种模式是，首先，慢性挣扎，慢性症状。这是那些经历过事件的人的一种模式。他们在开始时挣扎得很厉害，似乎根本无法从事件中恢复过来。他们在一段时间内持续挣扎，最终陷入长期的挣扎，长期的痛苦。如果是创伤性事件，他们会被困在重温事件中，
as if it could happen at any moment and they're in this sort of enduring state of anxious. fear in a sense. We see that in a minority of people, but it's very painful. The second pattern we see, we call the recovery pattern. And this is a pattern of which people suffer greatly initially. They have an acute reaction. And then they gradually begin to get better. This takes some time, but they gradually begin to regain functioning the way they had previously functioned. It may take a year or sometimes two years before they begin to feel like their life is kind of returned to normal. And finally, the third pattern we call the resilience trajectory is basically the most common
仿佛它随时可能发生，他们处于一种持久的焦虑状态。恐惧在某种意义上。我们在少数人身上看到了这一点，但这非常痛苦。我们看到的第二种模式，我们称之为恢复模式。这是一种人们最初遭受巨大痛苦的模式。他们有急性反应。然后他们逐渐开始好转。这需要一些时间，但他们逐渐开始恢复到以前的功能水平。可能需要一年甚至两年，他们才会开始觉得自己的生活恢复了正常。最后，第三种模式我们称之为韧性轨迹，基本上是最常见的
pattern we see. This is the pattern we see in the majority of people that have been exposed to potential trauma or a loss. They will struggle a little bit in the beginning. They're feeling some distress, some sadness, some intrusive memories. they're feeling the intensity of what has just happened. They may feel this for days, weeks at the most, sometimes a little bit longer,
我们看到的模式。这是我们在大多数接触过潜在创伤或丧失的人身上看到的模式。他们在开始时会挣扎一点。他们感到一些痛苦、一些悲伤、一些侵入性的记忆。他们感受到了刚刚发生的事情的强度。他们可能会感到几天，最多几周，有时会稍微长一点，
but then they return to a relatively normal level of functioning. They can be close to other people. They can concentrate and do their job. And we often refer to this as a stable trajectory of mental health. This is the resilient pattern. When we come back, nuances in how we think about trauma, resilience and different kinds of tragedies. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
但随后他们恢复到相对正常的运作水平。他们可以与他人亲近。他们可以集中注意力并完成工作。我们通常称之为心理健康的稳定轨迹。这就是韧性模式。当我们回来时，我们将探讨关于创伤、韧性和不同类型悲剧的细微差别。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There are many popular sayings about grief and loss. Grief is the price we pay for love. Grief is like the ocean. It comes in waves. You do not get over grief. You can only learn to walk alongside it.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。关于悲伤和丧失，有很多流行的说法。悲伤是我们为爱付出的代价。悲伤就像海洋。它一波又一波地袭来。你无法克服悲伤。你只能学会与它同行。
At Columbia University, George Bonano finds that science does not always support ideas that go viral on Instagram. George, one of the things that makes the study of trauma difficult is that the origins of people suffering can be very different. Listener, Lauren, had a question about that. She worries that much of the research on trauma focuses on single, life-changing moments.
在哥伦比亚大学，乔治·博纳诺发现科学并不总是支持那些在Instagram上疯传的观点。乔治，使创伤研究变得困难的一件事是，人们痛苦的根源可能非常不同。听众劳伦对此有一个问题。她担心很多关于创伤的研究都集中在单一的、改变人生的时刻。
What I find that the research is missing is complex trauma. A lot of it focuses on a single life event. and the natural resilience around grief and loss. However, trauma is far more complex than that. You see this in domestic violence victims who are silenced and swallow their trauma and live in abuse and have health complications. There's a high correlation with cancer, and there's obviously a high correlation in mental health,
我发现研究缺失的是复杂性创伤。很多研究集中在单一的生活事件上，以及围绕悲伤和丧失的自然韧性。然而，创伤远比那复杂得多。你在家庭暴力受害者身上看到了这一点，她们被噤声，吞下自己的创伤，生活在虐待中，并有健康并发症。这与癌症有很高的相关性，显然在心理健康方面也有很高的相关性，
PTSD, depression, anxiety. And I don't think that it's because they're not following a specific pattern to feel and embrace the pain and the ebb and flow. I think that it is an unnatural experience, counterintuitive to the normal human experience. And that is why it's more difficult to build resilience. And it's very, very different. Abuse is very different than losing someone. Chronic abuse is very different.
创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、抑郁、焦虑。我不认为这是因为她们没有遵循某种特定的模式去感受和拥抱痛苦以及起伏。我认为这是一种不自然的经历，违背了正常的人类体验。这就是为什么建立韧性更困难的原因。而且这非常、非常不同。虐待与失去某人非常不同。长期虐待非常不同。
George, what do you make of Lauren's argument? Do we see different patterns of resilience with, you know, domestic abuse compared with, say, the death of a spouse? Yes, we do. And I think I am very glad that Lauren made this comment. I think this is actually quite astute what she had said. There are a few things I want to comment on. Lauren mentioned complex trauma. And I think complex trauma has become a buzzword. in a sense for this kind of repeating traumatic event. But there's very little research. And this, to me, is a kind of a major sin from the research world that we need to try to
乔治，你如何看待劳伦的观点？我们是否看到了与家庭虐待相比，例如配偶去世时不同的韧性模式？是的，我们看到了。而且我认为我很高兴劳伦发表了这个评论。我认为她所说的实际上相当敏锐。有几件事我想评论一下。劳伦提到了复杂性创伤。我认为复杂性创伤在某种意义上已经成为这种重复性创伤事件的流行语。但研究很少。对我来说，这是研究界的一种重大罪过，我们需要努力去
understand it. But it's very hard to understand something like that. It's very hard to study it because you need to follow people over time. It is a fact that people find themselves in situations of repeated, very difficult and traumatic circumstances. chronic abuse is a prime example, you know, repeated exposure to life-threatening events. Poverty and violence, when poverty and violence come together, you have the same situation. People can become inured to it.
理解它。但要理解这样的事情非常困难。研究它非常困难，因为你需要长期跟踪人们。人们发现自己处于重复的、非常困难和创伤性的环境中是一个事实。长期虐待就是一个典型的例子，你知道，反复暴露在危及生命的事件中。贫困和暴力，当贫困和暴力结合在一起时，你就会遇到同样的情况。人们可能会对此变得麻木。
People can go on with enduring abuse because they see no way out, et cetera, but they are still suffering, these sort of inhuman experiences. What we see when we look at these events across the board is that people, are really struggling when they're dealing with chronicity, when they're dealing with these events that don't stop. And they don't show this low symptom healthy pattern. They don't necessarily show trauma or chronic symptoms either, but they show a lot of something. They're struggling. And they do have health problems. Lauren had made this point and she's absolutely right. Because our system, and this is a very important point, our stress response system, which is a
人们可以继续忍受虐待，因为他们看不到出路等等，但他们仍然在遭受这些非人的经历。当我们全面审视这些事件时，我们看到的是，当人们处理慢性问题时，当他们处理这些不会停止的事件时，他们真的在挣扎。他们没有表现出这种低症状的健康模式。他们也不一定表现出创伤或慢性症状，但他们表现出很多东西。他们在挣扎。他们确实有健康问题。劳伦提出了这一点，她是绝对正确的。因为我们的系统，这是一个非常重要的点，我们的压力反应系统，正如我之前所说，
as I've said before, is a wonderful thing. It was honed by millions of years of evolution. That stress response system than we have is designed by evolution, if I can say that, for acute life events. It's designed for emergencies. We are not built for chronic stress. It is somewhat inhuman. So when we are exposed to chronic abuse, chronic stress, chronic war, we begin to break down. The systems, these finely tuned systems we have that are in sync with each other begin to get out of sync. We become dysregulated. And that very quickly leads to health problems. So you see people essentially who are in the face of chronic trauma, chronic abuse, chronic poverty and violence, you see them limping along. And I think that's the best way to put it.
是一个美妙的东西。它经过了数百万年的进化磨练。我们拥有的那个压力反应系统，如果我可以这样说的话，是进化为急性生活事件设计的。它是为紧急情况设计的。我们不是为慢性压力而生的。这在某种程度上是不人道的。所以当我们暴露在长期虐待、长期压力、长期战争中时，我们开始崩溃。这些我们拥有的、彼此同步的微调系统开始不同步。我们变得失调。而这很快就会导致健康问题。所以你看到人们基本上在面对慢性创伤、长期虐待、长期贫困和暴力时，你看到他们步履蹒跚。我认为这是最好的表达方式。
They may be surviving, but they're not doing well. And we can document that. There just isn't enough research, really, to document that. But I appreciate the question very much, Lauren. George B. received lots of questions about how children experience loss and abuse and suffering. Here's one from a listener named Vera. I think the part that's missing here is in reference to childhood trauma, which was not discussed in this episode.
他们可能在生存，但他们过得并不好。我们可以记录这一点。真的没有足够的研究来记录这一点。但我非常感谢这个问题，劳伦。乔治·B收到了很多关于儿童如何经历丧失、虐待和痛苦的问题。这是一位名叫维拉的听众提出的问题。我认为这里缺失的部分是关于童年创伤的，这在这一集中没有讨论。
which I think a lot of people recognize as being very impactful, especially for children who don't exhibit trauma the same way, or trauma responses the same way that, say, an adult would, or they don't process it the same way. Lots of examples from the lives of people that I know, and so it would be interesting to come back with a discussion of the childhood trauma element. What does the research have to say, George, about potentially traumatic events in childhood
我认为很多人认识到这非常有影响力，特别是对于那些表现出创伤的方式与成年人不同，或者处理方式不同的儿童来说。我认识的人的生活中有很多例子，所以如果能回来讨论童年创伤的元素将会很有趣。乔治，研究对于童年时期潜在的创伤性事件有什么说法？
and whether their impact and outcomes differ from setbacks that we experience as adults? The point that Vera brought up is an interesting one. There's some confusion about this out there, and I think that's in part because much of the study of children and adversity focuses on really broad, caustic environments, poverty, chronic abuse, etc. And much of the research on adults has focused on acutely. life events, one-off traumatic events. And they show different patterns. Children tend to show more enduring symptoms, more struggle, even when they're not, you know, say, developing PTSD.
以及它们的影响和结果是否与我们成年后经历的挫折不同？维拉提出的观点很有趣。外面对此有一些困惑，我认为这部分是因为许多关于儿童和逆境的研究集中在非常广泛、腐蚀性的环境上，贫困、长期虐待等。而许多关于成年人的研究集中在急性生活事件、一次性的创伤事件上。它们表现出不同的模式。儿童往往表现出更持久的症状，更多的挣扎，即使他们没有，你知道，比如，发展出PTSD。
They're not doing that well. They might show problems in school. They might have health problems that you don't see so much in adults. But this, it turns out, is not about children and adults. It's about the type of event because there has been a lot of research on children who've gone through acute life events. And children who go through these isolated acute life events look a lot like adults. They show resilience at around the same level. Some children are traumatized and don't do very well, but most actually do quite well and they do quite well for a long time. By the same token, adults who have gone through chronic type events, which is, say, civil war, they don't look very well. They struggle the way children who've gone through chronic abuse struggle. So I think
他们过得并不好。他们可能会在学校表现出问题。他们可能会有在成年人身上不太常见的健康问题。但事实证明，这与儿童和成年人无关。这与事件的类型有关，因为已经有很多关于经历过急性生活事件的儿童的研究。经历过这些孤立的急性生活事件的儿童看起来很像成年人。他们在大致相同的水平上表现出韧性。有些儿童受到创伤，表现不太好，但大多数实际上表现得相当好，而且他们长期表现得相当好。同样地，经历过慢性类型事件（比如内战）的成年人，他们看起来并不好。他们像经历过长期虐待的儿童一样挣扎。所以我认为
There are nuances that we might think of that are specific to children because children are developing beings. So it's going to affect their development. Now, even if we talk about children or adults, we still have to fine tune this even more because children is a pretty large category. We know that children are very different than adolescents. Adolescence, in a way, have a completely different experience. So I want to make it clear that we still. still don't know that much about how different ages of children are going to affect this because it's so complex. There's still so much to know. We received some questions that focused on how different people might respond differently
我们可能会想到一些特定于儿童的细微差别，因为儿童是正在发育的个体。所以这会影响他们的发育。现在，即使我们谈论儿童或成年人，我们仍然必须进一步微调这一点，因为“儿童”是一个相当大的类别。我们知道儿童与青少年非常不同。青少年在某种程度上有着完全不同的经历。所以我想要明确的是，我们仍然不知道不同年龄的儿童将如何影响这一点，因为它太复杂了。还有太多需要了解的东西。我们收到了一些问题，重点关注不同的人可能如何做出不同的反应
to painful events. Here's listener, Jesse. How does social identity in society, gender, race, economic background, place in the environment, such as being in an environmentally insecure place, such as a constant flood zone, people who have a refugee status, etc. Would, do these impact resiliency? Do they diminish it? Does it depend? So how do demographic and environmental factors shape our response to setbacks in Lost, George? Great question. I appreciate the question, Jesse. They have an effect, but it's a surprisingly small effect.
对痛苦事件。这是听众杰西。社会中的社会身份、性别、种族、经济背景、在环境中的位置（例如处于环境不安全的地方，如持续的洪水区）、具有难民身份的人等，这些会影响韧性吗？它们会削弱它吗？这取决于什么？那么，人口统计学和环境因素如何塑造我们对丧失和挫折的反应，乔治？很好的问题。我很感谢这个问题，杰西。它们有影响，但影响小得惊人。
There is a consistent gender effect, for example, in the PTSD literature, that women tend to have slightly higher levels of PTSD. However, that difference is tiny, really. People have argued that women tend to be, because women are childbearing for the most part, that they have a different orientation to danger. They're much more attuned to danger, and that makes a slight difference in the prevalence.
例如，在PTSD文献中有一个一致的性别效应，即女性往往有略高的PTSD水平。然而，这种差异真的很小。人们争论说，女性往往因为主要是生育者，所以对危险有不同的取向。她们对危险更敏感，这在患病率上造成了微小的差异。
But again, it's a small difference. The overlap between men and women is to such a large extent that most men and women show the same patterns. We've seen differences in race in how people respond to potential trauma, but then those differences often go away when we control for economic differences. Refugees are very interesting because refugees are going through so much, so very much, but it turns out refugees actually cope remarkably well because they have to. They just have no choice but to. They're in situations where if they succumb to the things they've been exposed to,
但同样，这是一个很小的差异。男性和女性之间的重叠程度很大，以至于大多数男性和女性表现出相同的模式。我们已经看到种族在人们如何应对潜在创伤方面存在差异，但当我们控制经济差异时，这些差异往往会消失。难民非常有趣，因为难民正在经历很多、非常多的事情，但事实证明，难民实际上应对得非常好，因为他们必须这样做。他们别无选择。他们处于如果屈服于他们所经历的事情，
that's the end of the story for them. They won't survive. So you see lots of differences like this. And I think it's hard to generalize too much, but overall, because there's so much variability, the overall impact is quite minimal. We received an email from a listener named Brian who asks, I wonder if there is such a thing as trauma desensitization.
那就是他们的故事的终点。他们无法生存。所以你看到了很多这样的差异。我认为很难过度概括，但总的来说，因为变异性太大，总体影响相当小。我们收到了一位名叫布莱恩的听众的电子邮件，他问，我想知道是否存在创伤脱敏这回事。
If a person experiences trauma after, trauma after trauma, is it possible that they develop an immunity of sorts to new traumas? What do you think, George? That's a really interesting question. We actually did a study on this crime scene investigators, and we found that the crime scene investigators didn't respond to some really highly-aversive pictures we had, but they also didn't respond when they were given relatively neutral pictures. The pictures were designed to interfere with some other tasks they were doing,
如果一个人经历了一次又一次的创伤，他们是否可能对新的创伤产生某种免疫力？你认为呢，乔治？这是一个非常有趣的问题。我们实际上对犯罪现场调查员做了一项研究，我们发现犯罪现场调查员对我们拥有的一些非常令人反感的图片没有反应，但当给他们相对中性的图片时，他们也没有反应。这些图片旨在干扰他们正在做的其他任务，
whereas the average person was very much thrown off when they saw these disturbing pictures. So the crime scene investigators were essentially not responding to much of anything. They were just kind of going through in this, for lack of a better word, a little bit deadened to it. So I think that that's the danger there, is that not just becoming desensitized the trauma, but being around a lot of serious pain and made. just desensitized people in general. They may adopt this kind of deadened kind of attitude. I mean, you have to wonder then about people who are confronting suffering on a daily basis. I'm thinking about doctors and nurses. I mean, you're seeing people coming in and suffering every day,
而普通人在看到这些令人不安的图片时会非常困扰。所以犯罪现场调查员基本上对任何事情都没有反应。他们只是以这种方式经历，用一个更好的词来说，对它有点麻木。所以我认为危险在于，不仅仅是对创伤脱敏，而是身处大量严重的痛苦和残缺中，可能只是让人们普遍脱敏。他们可能会采取这种麻木的态度。我的意思是，你不得不怀疑那些每天面对痛苦的人。我想到的是医生和护士。我的意思是，你每天看到人们进来并遭受痛苦，
but you're seeing them every day. And after some time, is there a risk that you say, okay, this is just one more broken knee. This is one more gunshot wound. It's just one more, you know, body and pain. And I can go on and it's not very much. Yes, absolutely. In fact, we confronted this a little bit during the COVID-19 pandemic, and I collaborated with somebody in the emergency department at Columbia, there's a culture in medicine. And I think this is probably true among first responders, firefighters and a lot of other places, military as well.
但你每天都在看他们。一段时间后，是否存在一种风险，你会说，好吧，这只是又一个骨折的膝盖。这只是又一个枪伤。这只是又一个，你知道，痛苦的身体。我可以继续，这没什么大不了的。是的，绝对。事实上，我们在COVID-19大流行期间稍微面对过这个问题，我与哥伦比亚大学急诊科的人合作过，医学界有一种文化。我认为这在急救人员、消防员和许多其他地方，军队中也是如此。
There's a culture of stoicism, a sense that you're here to do this job, and their own personal reactions are not relevant. It's seen as your own problem. are not in the picture here. You're here to do this job and help these people. And that has led to some casualties. And I think during COVID-19, when emergency departments were being overwhelmed, there were some very high-profile suicides by the emergency department staff. And that led to a lot of reflection and examination of how the medical profession views itself. And it led to actually what we learned when we looked into it was that a number of the emergency department staff
有一种斯多葛主义的文化，一种你在这里是为了做这份工作的感觉，他们自己的个人反应是不相关的。这被视为你自己的问题。不在画面中。你在这里是为了做这份工作并帮助这些人。这导致了一些伤亡。我认为在COVID-19期间，当急诊科不堪重负时，急诊科工作人员发生了一些非常引人注目的自杀事件。这导致了对医学界如何看待自身的大量反思和审视。当我们深入研究时，我们实际上学到的是，一些急诊科工作人员
were on their own creating informal kind of support networks to somehow process all this stuff that they were facing because none existed. And I think that led to some awareness, and I honestly don't know what came of it, but it led to some awareness that this is not a good situation to not be able to talk about it, share stories, decompressed from these kinds of experiences. It seems like it's really a necessary thing. When we come back, listeners share some of the ways they've addressed tough times in their lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
在他们自己创建非正式的支持网络，以某种方式处理他们所面临的所有这些事情，因为根本不存在这样的网络。我认为这导致了一些意识，我真的不知道结果如何，但它导致了一些意识，即无法谈论它、分享故事、从这些经历中减压并不是一个好的情况。这似乎真的是一件必要的事情。当我们回来时，听众分享了他们应对生活中艰难时刻的一些方式。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Clinical psychologist George Bonano studies how we respond to loss and tragedy. One way many of us do this is by reaching out to others for help. But sometimes the people we reach out to don't know what to say, so they don't say anything at all. A listener named Colin has this suggestion. I've worked with grief camps for many years. And one of the most significant things I learned at camp was Becky Byrne, the founder of Annie's Hope in St. Louis,
这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。临床心理学家乔治·博纳诺研究我们如何应对丧失和悲剧。我们许多人这样做的一种方式是向他人寻求帮助。但有时我们寻求帮助的人不知道该说什么，所以他们什么都不说。一位名叫科林的听众有这个建议。我多年来一直从事悲伤营地的工作。我在营地学到的最重要的事情之一是，圣路易斯Annie's Hope的创始人贝基·伯恩，
would have conversations with people about the person who had died, like you. any other conversation, it was just paying attention to someone without laying all of this, oh, you must be so sad on top of it. I just thought that was remarkable, and I've tried to do that since. So Colin suggests that rather than trying to offer commentary to help someone suffering from a loss or setback, just paying close attention to them is itself a form of comfort. They seem to be a deep wisdom in this approach, George. Is there research on how best to talk to people who are going through grief or despair? There is some research, not as much as one would hope to see, but there is some research. And what that research has shown is that there are comments,
会像你一样与人们谈论去世的人。任何其他对话，只是关注某人，而不把所有这些“哦，你一定很伤心”强加给他们。我只是觉得这很了不起，从那以后我一直尝试这样做。所以科林建议，与其试图提供评论来帮助遭受丧失或挫折的人，不如仅仅密切关注他们本身就是一种安慰。这种方法似乎蕴含着深刻的智慧，乔治。关于如何最好地与正在经历悲伤或绝望的人交谈，是否有相关研究？有一些研究，虽然没有人们希望看到的那么多，但确实有一些研究。研究表明，有一些评论，
there are definite things that people can say that during bereavement that grieving people find annoying or unhelpful. And they run the gamut from, you know, you'll be fine or, you know, I'm thinking about you or whatever that they might say. And in fact, I think Colin's point, and was very well put, and I embrace it. I think that, in fact, what bereaved people, I think probably most would value is somebody who's just simply there to talk with them at whatever level. A great example of this was actually, I was writing a paper. I was doing a research study with a brilliant woman, a very wonderful woman named Lisa Kapps, who was a linguist at Berkeley, and she was given a cancer diagnosis at a terribly young age
在丧亲期间，人们确实可以说一些话，让悲伤的人感到恼火或无益。它们涵盖了从“你会好起来的”或“我在想你”或无论他们可能说的任何话。事实上，我认为科林的观点表达得非常好，我赞同它。我认为，事实上，丧亲者，我想大多数人可能最看重的是一个仅仅在那里与他们交谈的人，无论在什么层面。一个很好的例子是，我当时正在写一篇论文。我正在与一位才华横溢、非常出色的女性丽莎·卡普斯进行一项研究，她是伯克利的一位语言学家，她在非常年轻的时候就被诊断出患有癌症，
and was going to die in six months. We were doing a research study at the time on bereavement, and we were doing it remotely over the phone in those days. And she said to me, you know, George, I would really like to just talk about the research when we meet. I don't want to talk about my cancer. I don't want to talk about facing death. I just want to talk about the research. And she had about six months to live.
并且将在六个月内去世。我们当时正在进行一项关于丧亲的研究，在那些日子里，我们是通过电话远程进行的。她对我说：“你知道，乔治，当我们见面时，我真的只想谈论研究。我不想谈论我的癌症。我不想谈论面对死亡。我只想谈论研究。”她还有大约六个月的生命。
And that's what we did. She wanted to be just a normal person as best as she could until she died. That was her choice. So people have their ideas about what they want to do. And I think it's very important for us in a supporting role to be sensitive to that and not to engage in canned responses or platitudes. because people do definitely react negatively to them. A listener named Wendy reached out to share her story of managing grief.
这就是我们所做的。她想尽可能地做一个正常人，直到她去世。那是她的选择。所以人们对他们想做的事情有自己的想法。我认为对于我们这些处于支持角色的人来说，保持敏感并避免使用套话或陈词滥调非常重要。因为人们确实会对它们产生负面反应。一位名叫温迪的听众分享了她管理悲伤的故事。
Her husband passed away five years ago. At first, Wendy and her then 14-year-old son tried to just get through the day. She didn't like talking about her grief, but then after about six months, she started attending a grief class where people were required to tell the story of their partner's death. People could barely get through their narrative, and it was just horrible.
她的丈夫五年前去世了。起初，温迪和她当时14岁的儿子试图仅仅度过每一天。她不喜欢谈论她的悲伤，但大约六个月后，她开始参加一个悲伤课程，人们被要求讲述他们伴侣去世的故事。人们几乎无法完成他们的叙述，这简直太可怕了。
people crying, really uncomfortable. But after, like, they made us do this three times, the third time you do it, it starts to become almost like a habit, right? And I realized that it, you know, the repetition makes it manageable. And it's, you know, to the day, I still feel like I can talk about it without losing things because of that practice. The other thing they did, I didn't appreciate the time. It was talking about your partner, like how you met, what you loved about them.
人们哭泣，真的非常不舒服。但之后，就像，他们让我们做了三次，第三次你做的时候，它开始变得几乎像一种习惯，对吧？我意识到，你知道，重复使它变得可控。而且，你知道，直到今天，我仍然觉得我可以谈论它而不会因为那种练习而失去控制。他们做的另一件事，我当时并不欣赏。那是谈论你的伴侣，比如你们是如何相遇的，你爱他们的什么。
And, you know, that just seemed normal and nice. But a couple of years on, what I realized is the first few years, your grief is about you, like everything you lost. But as time goes on, I feel like that's kind of gone away. And it's more, I think, about what my husband lost, what he will never see or experience. be part of and people don't talk about him as time goes on and it's almost like they're they're dying again because their their memories not even kept and you know that's where my son comes in because he you know he never wanted to talk about his father's death refused and fine he was old enough that I didn't want to force him to to go to counseling but what he's very happy to do is talk about his
而且，你知道，那看起来很正常也很美好。但几年后，我意识到前几年，你的悲伤是关于你自己的，比如你失去的一切。但随着时间的推移，我觉得那种感觉已经消失了。更多的是，我认为是关于我丈夫失去了什么，他永远不会看到或经历什么。成为其中的一部分，随着时间的推移，人们不再谈论他，这几乎就像他们再次死去一样，因为他们的记忆甚至没有被保留，你知道，这就是我儿子的用武之地，因为他，你知道，他从来不想谈论他父亲的去世，拒绝了，没关系，他已经足够大了，我不想强迫他去咨询，但他非常乐意做的是谈论他
you know, his dad's life. And we talk about them all the time and laugh and remember, you know, good, bad, goofy things about his dad. And I think that's normal. That's healthy. There's been debate in the field, George, about the utility of getting people to talk about their grief. In the aftermath of 9-11, for example, it was widely believed that getting people to describe their suffering and horror was a way to reduce their suffering and horror. I just watched a very good movie, My Dead Friend Zoe, which is all about the importance of opening up and sharing one story of tragedy with others. What does the research say about the utility of doing this, George? It depends really on the type of the tragedy itself, the type of tragedy. The comment
你知道，他父亲的生活。我们一直谈论他们，大笑并记住，你知道，关于他父亲的好、坏、傻的事情。我认为那是正常的。那是健康的。乔治，在该领域一直存在关于让人们谈论他们的悲伤是否有用的争论。例如，在9/11之后，人们普遍认为让人们描述他们的痛苦和恐惧是减少他们痛苦和恐惧的一种方式。我刚刚看了一部非常好的电影《我死去的挚友佐伊》，它完全是关于敞开心扉并与他人分享悲剧故事的重要性。乔治，研究对于这样做是否有用有什么说法？这真的取决于悲剧本身的类型，悲剧的类型。温迪所做的评论
that Wendy made about talking about a partner's death, that's a very interesting point that she made. And I think it makes a lot of sense in this particular case, when one is lost, a loved one. Now, there are interesting treatments for people who are really struggling with grief when part of that treatment is to review the death event, how the partner died in great detail. And this is, I think, particularly useful when people are struggling to get over a loss. And the reason seems to be because we often have beliefs about what the death event was for the person and how it related to us. And what their experience was, what our experience was, whether we were in any way at fault or whether we had some sense of blame.
关于谈论伴侣的去世，这是一个非常有趣的观点。我认为在这一特定案例中，当一个人失去亲人时，这非常有意义。现在，对于那些真正与悲伤作斗争的人来说，有一些有趣的治疗方法，其中部分治疗方法是详细回顾死亡事件，伴侣是如何去世的。我认为，当人们努力克服丧失时，这特别有用。原因似乎是因为我们经常对死亡事件对那个人意味着什么以及它与我们的关系有某种信念。以及他们的经历是什么，我们的经历是什么，我们是否在任何方面有过错，或者我们是否有某种责备感。
And when people who review these, the death event, they for the first time really take a good long look at it. And it's a way of kind of putting clear in their minds, this is what happened to this person that I love. And sometimes some of the distortions that we imposed upon it drift away when we do that. As Wendy said, repeating this a few times, you get kind of used to it. This is what happened. And in a way, this is what our minds want to do. Our minds want to say, yes, this is what happened. I now have to live with this reality that this is what happened.
当人们回顾这些死亡事件时，他们第一次真正地仔细审视了它。这是一种在他们心中理清思路的方式，这就是发生在我所爱的人身上的事情。有时我们强加给它的一些扭曲在这样做时会消失。正如温迪所说，重复几次，你就会习惯它。这就是发生的事情。在某种程度上，这就是我们的大脑想要做的。我们的大脑想要说，是的，这就是发生的事情。我现在必须接受这个现实，即这就是发生的事情。
And I move on. I recalibrate and do whatever I need to do in my life. So I think in this particular case, it can be very useful. I wouldn't say it's useful for anyone who's grieving. I think it's useful for people who are struggling, particularly with their loss. But it's not something that everybody should. be doing. In fact, there is some research suggesting this is counterproductive for people who are basically not struggling afterwards. It, in a sense, puts them in a situation where they become
然后我继续前进。我重新调整状态，做我生活中需要做的事情。所以我认为在这种特殊情况下，这可能非常有益。我不会说这对所有处于悲伤中的人都适用。我认为这对那些正在挣扎的人，特别是因失去亲人而挣扎的人是有益的。但这并不是每个人都应该做的事情。事实上，有一些研究表明，对于那些在事后并没有陷入挣扎的人来说，这样做反而适得其反。从某种意义上说，这把他们置于一种境地，使他们变得
confused about what actually happened, and maybe I should be grieving or maybe I should be feeling more trauma symptoms, or maybe I am traumatized and I don't know it. So it very much depends. A listener named Mariah reached out to share how she dealt with two losses in rapid succession. first the loss of her brother in 2018 to a fentanyl overdose, and then the following year the loss of her infant son, Liam. Here's Mariah. So after Liam died, I told myself that I would take two weeks to just lie in a dark room, do nothing, be nothing, just grieve.
对实际发生的事情感到困惑，也许我会想我是否应该感到悲伤，或者我是否应该有更多的创伤症状，或者我是否受到了创伤而自己却不知道。所以这在很大程度上取决于个人情况。一位名叫玛丽亚的听众联系我们，分享了她如何应对接连发生的两次丧亲之痛。首先是2018年她哥哥因芬太尼过量死亡，第二年她又失去了婴儿儿子利亚姆。以下是玛丽亚的讲述。利亚姆去世后，我告诉自己，我要花两周时间躺在黑暗的房间里，什么都不做，什么都不想，只是悲伤。
But in reality, it wasn't really practical. And I think I lasted about five days. And somehow there was the impulse there to get up, to get out of bed, to move. was always there. It was kind of like like a muscle memory that in the beginning I kind of relied on. It was something instinctive. At the same time, though, I think that the fact that I had a job where I felt a lot of purpose, I had a lot of responsibility, and I give major credit to like colleagues at the time who really let me return to work without too much handholding, without too much like awkwardness. So work was able to be this medium
但实际上，这并不现实。我想我只坚持了大约五天。不知何故，那种起床、下床、走动的冲动一直都在。这就像是一种肌肉记忆，起初我依赖这种记忆。这是一种本能。但与此同时，我认为我拥有一份让我感到非常有意义的工作，我承担了很多责任，我非常感谢当时的同事，他们真的让我能够回到工作中，而没有过多的呵护，也没有过多的尴尬。所以工作能够成为一种媒介，
where people basically like treated me normal and it was a huge, it was a huge relief. So all of that is to say that I really, I don't view resilience as like a character trait. I don't think of it as a quality that some people have and some people don't have in my experience. It really is like a practice.
让人们基本上像对待正常人一样对待我，这是一种巨大的解脱。所以这一切都是为了说明，我真的不认为韧性是一种性格特征。我不认为这是一种有些人有而有些人没有的品质。根据我的经验，它确实像是一种练习。
So George Mariah goes on to say that she was effectively compartmental, mentalizing. That's the way she thought about what she was doing. But contrary to how that word is generally used, she felt that it was a good thing, a helpful thing. Can it be? Yes, absolutely. I think that's absolutely correct. What she was doing makes a lot of sense to me, and it's an experience that other people have talked about. It's the idea that I think returning to work is very important because it's a part of who we are. So when we're struggling with grief, it's very important. to remember that we do have a role in the world. And it is a sort of a compartmentalization
乔治，玛丽亚接着说，她实际上是在进行“隔绝化”处理。这就是她对自己所作所为的看法。但与这个词通常的用法相反，她觉得这是一件好事，一件有益的事情。这可能吗？是的，绝对可能。我认为这是完全正确的。她的做法对我来说很有道理，这也是其他人谈到过的经历。我认为重返工作岗位非常重要，因为它是我们自我的一部分。所以当我们陷入悲伤时，记住我们在世界上仍然扮演着某种角色是非常重要的。这是一种隔绝化，
because maybe we'll return home to a quiet room or a quiet house and where the loss is still much more pervasive. We might take that time to allow ourselves to feel that pain a little bit more then. And that's very much what a lot of people do. Moray also points out that tragedies like the death of a child were a lot more common in the past. And it makes her think about how previous generations grappled with grief. So I guess, you know, on the one hand, it kind of like bonds me to mothers everywhere and kind of reminds me that this tragedy is very common. But it also kind of, it kind of leads me to think that like maybe we're a little too precious
因为也许我们回到家会面对一个安静的房间或安静的房子，而那里的失落感仍然更加普遍。我们可能会利用那段时间让自己多感受一点痛苦。这确实是许多人所做的。玛丽亚还指出，像孩子死亡这样的悲剧在过去要普遍得多。这让她思考前几代人是如何应对悲伤的。所以我想，一方面，这让我与各地的母亲们产生了联系，也提醒我这种悲剧非常普遍。但这也让我觉得，也许我们对悲伤太小心翼翼了，
with grief. Like, maybe sometimes an appropriate response or strategy for tragedy, right, like a resilience building framework, I guess, is like, okay, get out of bed and go to work. Like, I could definitely be oversimplifying it. And I'm definitely only talking about my experience. But it kind of feels like nowadays, we can afford to be derailed by tragedy because we have this, like, incredibly high standard of living where we're also not, like, needed in the fields tomorrow and we don't have eight other kids to care for.
就像，也许有时应对悲剧的适当反应或策略，比如一种建立韧性的框架，就是：好吧，起床去工作。我肯定是在过度简化。而且我绝对只是在谈论我自己的经历。但感觉现在我们似乎可以承受被悲剧击垮的后果，因为我们拥有这种极高的生活水平，而且我们也不需要明天就去田里干活，也不需要照顾另外八个孩子。
So it's not that, you know, the mothers of the 1800s. were not resilient, or they were, were not resilient. I think it's that they lived in a society that had, like, demands on them that necessitated what we would say are like acts of resilience. So, George, there are millions of people in the world who are still in the situation that Mariah describes, and it makes me wonder how much of grief is cultural. Different cultures around the world treat grief differently. What can we learn from other cultures and other times?
所以并不是说19世纪的母亲们没有韧性。我认为是因为她们生活在一个对她们有要求的社会中，这些要求迫使她们表现出我们所说的“韧性行为”。所以，乔治，世界上有数百万人仍然处于玛丽亚所描述的那种境地，这让我怀疑悲伤在多大程度上是文化性的。世界各地的不同文化对悲伤的处理方式不同。我们能从其他文化和时代学到什么？
Mariah's comments are really spot on, very astute actually. There are definitely cultural differences in grief. Grief varies greatly by culture and history. Some cultures have very prescribed mourning ceremonies, and people engage in these ceremonies, whether they're grieving or not, they do what the cultural practice dictates they do, and there's something very comforting in that, I think. Historically as well, we see these differences, as Mariah pointed out, out there was a time when people had enormous numbers of children because so many of them died.
玛丽亚的评论非常到位，实际上非常敏锐。悲伤确实存在文化差异。悲伤因文化和历史而异。有些文化有非常明确的哀悼仪式，人们会参与这些仪式，无论他们是否感到悲伤，他们都会按照文化习俗的要求去做，我认为这其中有一种非常令人安慰的东西。从历史上看，我们也看到了这些差异，正如玛丽亚所指出的，曾经有一段时间，人们生育大量的孩子，因为其中许多孩子会夭折。
And they did grieve children, but they didn't grieve them the same way we think of it now. And I like this point that Mara made that, you know, we have the luxury in a sense of indulging in our pain, which on the one hand allows us to really become aware of what it feels like and the value of life. But on the other hand, there's a danger in that we stay in that pain for longer than we should. So there's a, the imperative to get on with one's life with maybe as a little less now because we're not in the fields, we're not, we're not fleeing predators, but these, these things do actually make us move forward. So we see a lot of these cultural pressures to do things certain ways. Some of them are time worn and they work very well
他们确实为孩子感到悲伤，但他们悲伤的方式与我们现在所想的不同。我喜欢玛丽亚提到的这一点，即我们从某种意义上说拥有沉溺于痛苦的奢侈，这在某种程度上使我们能够真正意识到这种感觉是什么以及生命的价值。但另一方面，这也有危险，因为我们可能会在痛苦中停留比应该停留的时间更长。因此，继续生活的必要性现在可能减少了，因为我们不需要去田里干活，也不需要逃避捕食者，但这些事情确实促使我们前进。所以我们看到很多这种要求人们以特定方式行事的文化压力。其中一些是经久不衰的，而且非常有效，
to give people what they need to do so they can move on. George Bonano is a clinical psychologist at Columbia University. He's the author of The End of Trauma, how the new science of resilience is changing how we think about PTSD. George, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Shankar, it's been my pleasure. Nice to talk with you again. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul,
能给人们提供他们所需要的东西，让他们能够继续前进。乔治·博纳诺是哥伦比亚大学的临床心理学家。他是《创伤的终结：韧性的新科学如何改变我们对创伤后应激障碍的看法》一书的作者。乔治，非常感谢你今天参加《Hidden Brain》节目。尚卡尔，这是我的荣幸。很高兴再次与你交谈。《Hidden Brain》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、
Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy today's conversation and find Hidden Brain to be useful or thought-provoking, please consider joining Hidden Brain Plus. It's our subscriber-only podcast feed, where we bring you ideas and conversations you won't hear anywhere else.
克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢今天的对话，并觉得《Hidden Brain》有用或发人深省，请考虑加入 Hidden Brain Plus。这是我们的订阅用户专属播客频道，我们会在那里为你提供你在其他任何地方都听不到的想法和对话。
You'll be helping us provide the fuel for the research, writing, fact-checking and sound design that is involved in every episode of the show. To subscribe, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, you can sign up at apple.com slash hiddenbrain. Again, those sites are support.hiddenbrain.org and apple.com slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你将帮助我们为节目每一集所涉及的研究、写作、事实核查和声音设计提供动力。要订阅，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，可以在 apple.com/hiddenbrain 注册。再次重申，这些网站是 support.hiddenbrain.org 和 apple.com/hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。